e
good morning everybody we're going to
get going here it's
9:32 um
before we start this morning
representative Hicks you are up to lead
pledge I've actually been keep I've been
keeping a list this year representative
list okay uh good morning everybody uh
Mr clerk if you would could you call the
attendance
please okay Vice chairman in power
representative Guffy yeah okay sorry
okay I'm sorry uh click is here
representative lales I'm here
representative Kella representative
Kelly representative
awood representative Brown here
representative kahill here
representative stavis here
representative
Tetro representative TR 11
representative Gilman represent majori
here representative Gallagher
representative hick I'm here
representative Howland here
representative priest here
representative Frack here and Mr
chairman
here thank you Mr clerk good morning
everybody once again we're going to go
ahead and open up our first public
hearing it's SP 538 relative to zoning
procedures concerning residential
housing I see the prime sponsor Senator
Perkins quoka is here and you have the
floor well thank you very much chairman
and members of um Municipal and County
committee I'm happy to be here with you
this morning for the record I am Senator
Rebecca Perkins quoka representing
Senate District 21 city of Portsmouth
and the towns of Durham Lee Madbury
Newcastle newfields Newington and New
Market I have all the news as you know
today I'm introducing s SP 538 an act
relative to zoning procedures concerning
residential housing as you all know our
state is in the midst of a crisis not
only are there not enough housing units
readily available for New Hampshire
families but the costs of those units
are simply becoming too unattainable for
the average citizen for years
circumnavigating this crisis has been
one of my main priorities to ensure that
New Hampshire can be a place that future
Generations can call
home I am calling s SP 538 home nibus
some of you may have heard this name as
amended by the Senate it is now a
three-part bill that offers some some
additional solutions to address this
dire situation our state is facing we
all know there is no Silver Bullet to
solve the housing crisis we'll need all
the different tools that we can muster
and put those tools into our
municipality's
hands this piece of legislation at this
point is largely enabling respecting
that our cities and towns are really the
ones that are on the front lines of
solving the housing crisis
to walk you through a couple of the
pieces inside the bill the first part
offers um T local property tax credits
for the downtown conversion of office
commercial or industrial space into
residential units as such it would have
to comply with local pre-existing zoning
ordinances and when enacted our
municipalities would have to Define what
their downtown is for the buildings to
qualify the second part of the bill
enables our select boards to amend
zoning this means that the zoning
process could be conducted more than
once a year and allow for greater public
input and
hearing the third part of the bill now
allows for alternative parking
arrangements for housing units to be
considered by our local boards this
aspect makes it possible for not all
parking spaces required for residential
units to be on site which would also
help provide a tool to lower the cost of
housing ultimately to the end
user some parts of this bill have been
removed by the Senate and I just want to
clarify those for everybody here one was
concerning soil based slot sizing which
is no longer part of the bill and
another concerned inclusionary zoning
which is also not in here as amended by
the
Senate this sp sp 538 is intended to be
a technical Bill addressing a highly
technical problem with hopefully
Technical Solutions which again are
passed to our municipalities who are
really the front lines of this
crisis I also view this as a
conversation with you about the the
board about how we can move this bill
forward and I welcome questions I also
hope that we can all work together to
continue to address this challenge as it
faces us this year and in the years to
come with that Mr chairman I'm happy to
answer any questions that you may have
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you Senator thank you for being
here and introducing this bill and I was
particularly interested with regards to
um section six it's a new section uh
starting on page two line 16 so it's
adoption of zoning ordinances
alternative procedure so my
understanding is that this
um the legislative body in in a town
would would no longer be the body which
uh passes zoning
ordinances and that would be um
transferred to the governing body so I
understand that planning boards they're
responsible for um researching and
analyzing and there's a process that um
takes many months typically I believe
that they they they the process they
start looking at things um maybe in the
the summer or early fall would could you
explain how that would what that would
look like would they still be part of it
would they still be putting forward
ordinances and the only difference would
be that that the um the governing body
would would uh pass
or would vote to to pass ordinances
could you explain that a little bit more
for me thank you yeah sure no thank you
for the question um because again
there's a lot of technical pieces here
so just as an important clarification at
the outset the local legislative body
would have to take action to delegate
this authority to the governing body so
in other words there would still have to
be a town warrant to hand over authority
to the select board on zoning ordinances
so that that's an action that has to
take place in the first place approved
by all the voters um what this does is
open up an option to essentially as you
said um allow the governing body to play
the role of you know facil facilitating
further public hearings once that
referral is received from the planning
board or not I think each municipality
would have the flexibility to do that
planning boards often do play a role
which I think is a really um important
piece and so um I know on the council we
would sort of open up an ordinance refer
it to the planning board that's where it
would experience some public hearing it
would come back to the council you know
and and go through additional Hearing in
towns I think the procedure is probably
a little more flexible but um but again
that's something that could be developed
by our towns and cities who are really
in the best position to figure out um
them representative
Holland thank you for taking my question
actually just to summarize what you just
said uh so this is in essence is really
giving the power that a lot of
communities that have a town Charter
they're able to already do this so this
is extending that ability and more
flexibility to SP2 towns that's exactly
right representative any town could
adopt as Durham has um you know the Town
Council form of government and do this
today
y further questions representative power
thank you for take thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question so
with regards to the same section I I'm
noticing and I might be missing
something but so as you as you had
reiterated that this is enabling
legislation um for for this transf for
of authority I don't see a rescind
mechanism was that an oversight or was
that um on
purpose that's a good question I would
have to look into existing statute but I
um I assume there are other powers that
can be delegated through warrant to a
select board and so there's probably an
existing statutory mechanism to resend
it um but I would be happy to look into
that and get back to you we I I'm
assuming we weren't trying to reinvent
happened further
questions seeing none thank you very
thank you Mr chairman good morning
committee members my name is Ben Frost
I'm the deputy executive director and
chief legal officer at New Hampshire
Housing and I'm here to express New
Hampshire housing's strong and
enthusiastic support for Senate Bill
538 closer is that better okay um I you
know Senator Perkins quoka uh very ay uh
introduced the legislation and described
its import uh just underscore the
importance of anything the legislature
can do to help meet uh the state's
housing crisis um this is a crisis of
housing Supply uh and we we simply do
not have enough uh housing to meet the
current or anticipated future demand
based upon population growth and
changing household composition uh the uh
elements of Senate Bill 538 uh on their
surface may not uh appear necessarily
except for the the provision dealing
with RSA 79e to be dealing directly with
housing but to the extent you make it uh
more efficient to change the zoning
ordinance to the extent you make it
easier to to meet uh local parking
requirements then it it becomes easier
to develop housing uh and that any of
these measures would be a welcome relief
to the pressures that developers are
facing as they try to make these deals
happen um the the first two well
sections three and four uh are dealing
with RSA 79e which is the community
revitalization tax relief incentive this
was established by the legislature in
2006 and has become one of the most
important tools that municipalities have
to encourage development it was
originally conceived as a uh a Downtown
Development Bill uh and and really it
was focused on
rehabilitating call them der structures
in downtown areas uh to give the
property owners an incentive a tax
incentive essentially uh that they can
use to help underwrite the costs of
development um and it has taken off
since then it's been used and because of
its success and and its widespread
adoption by municipalities this is
purely enabling
legislation uh it it has been used uh
for a variety of different U measures
this uh what is proposed here in senal
538 is a new measure a welcome measure
that would
focus explicitly on the conversions of
existing commercial industrial
essentially non-residential uses for
conversion to residential uses again if
a municipality wants to do this this is
enabling legislation then it could adopt
this measure to allow for uh the RSA 79e
to apply to these kinds of developments
um with regard to sections five and six
this is the uh the change and
representative Howland I think you you
very um appropriately noted this is like
towns with a town counil form of
government Charter where the the local
legislative body uh is the local
governing body uh and cities too also
have the same structure um the planning
board would still be involved uh it
would still have the same role it does
have now it's just changing who
ultimately has the adoption power over
zoning ordinances and as Senator Perkins
quote Perkins quoka noted uh this
requires a municipality the voters to
say yes this is what we want to do it's
enabling legislation so if the voters
don't want to do it it doesn't happen uh
the last section uh oh representative
power you had asked about re uh power to
resend um in the absence of specific
language generally speaking uh the same
process is used uh to resend something
that is enabling uh that has been
previously granted and that's a
generally recognized principle of
law um so it although that the its
absence I note um and you you certainly
could put it in there it's not
absolutely necessary the last section um
section seven deals with um the parking
requirements uh Park nationally um in in
planning circles the the issue of
parking and parking requirements has
become a a really weighty discussion
because of the difficulty that so many
developments have in meeting local
parking requirements and yet uh
municipalities stand behind those
standards so this is an opportunity for
a uh developer to propose some sort of
alternative uh that meets the standards
but is not necessarily wholly on site
and I think that that would be a welcome
change to uh the uh the difficulties
that uh developers have in meeting uh
local parking
requirements uh all that said uh New
Hampshire housing uh strongly supports
this legislation urges you to recommend
it ought to pass U we'd be happy to work
with you on any amendments uh you wish
and I'd be happy to take any
questions representative Brown thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question Mr Frost I have two quick
questions so uh under U line 22 2324 it
talks about the property tax page number
uh f um first page um it talks about the
property tax relief granted and it's
once in a 20-year period so is there a
limit on the amount of property tax that
can be
given relief representative this is a
really good question it's not it's not
the the amount of the tax there's no
there's not a dollar number uh the way
RSA 79e works and this is current law
and has been since
2006 um a a property owner where a
municipality has adopted the provisions
of the law will present to the local
governing body uh the select board
typically uh an application for use of
79e in changing the use in the
originally it was substantial
Rehabilitation and that was wherever a
property owner was engaged in as defined
substantial
Rehabilitation and if the uh select
board granted this then they would
determine the time period of tax relief
and the tax relief would take the form
of of um of not taxing the increased
valuation that's attributable to the
change of use but rather T continuing to
tax it on its pre pre-rehabilitation
uh assessed valuation for a period of
time um and and this this relies on the
same structure so the base period tends
to be 5 years although a municipality a
select board may choose to do less than
five if it wishes to there's a lot of
flexibility in this law um but five
years is the typical base period and
then you add on uh additional things for
uh provision of housing or if it's an
historic structure um so ultimately you
could get up to 13 14 or 15 years if you
have the if you meet all of the the the
levers that get pulled and the select
board says yes to well of those the
discretion really is wholly within the
select board to decide how long but
there's not a a specific dollar value
okay thanks U Mr chairman quick followup
go ahead so uh also in regard to the
parking that you mentioned um today with
the way people working remote some days
of the week sometimes full-time uh
remote um how do you determine the the
parking requirement when you've got
residential now some of these people
could be working from home full-time
some of the people could be just
traveling and and it refers to hours of
the day that you might have to have
additional parking available thank you
that's a great question and uh I would
say that that the science is still
trying to catch up with uh the actual
patterns of use but I think that the
current standards that many
municipalities have are well in excess
of what is actually needed irrespective
of their actual use so even with with
changes in remote work uh so that people
are occupying commercial structures less
occupying residential structures more um
it you know the parking standards tend
to be uh well in excess of what is
required even with those changes uh I I
will note that
in um single family development most
municipalities do not have specific
parking standards uh that it's you know
a single family home is expected to have
adequate space for parking they don't
they they regulate where the driveway
will go but they don't say how much
capacity that driveway is going to have
for parking okay thank you very much
represent
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I just a
definitions question on um page two line
36 how under the um terms of this bill
representative savis that's a great
question it is one that uh we have been
dealing with in other legislation this
session uh specifically the uh the fire
code and the building code so RSA 153
and 155a
respectively um generally uh
non-transient occupancy is deemed to be
uh either and I I I'm forgetting
precisely how it's worded in both of
those laws it's either more than 30 days
or 30 days or more so it's 30 days is
generally the the uh dividing line
between Trent and non-rent
occupancy follow up thank you Mr chair
so given that continued work on the
definition of this how would local
government governments and planning
board interpret
this well in in the absence of a
specific definition here I would refer
code further
questions representative
Ood thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question this morning on page
two starting at line three
through line 10 I've run into this
definition of local legislative body
elsewhere in the the Planning and Zoning
chapter and that they're saying
following the basic forms of
government um is not official ballot
referenda a basic form of town
government and would it not be included
as an item
G lowercase
G in this list of types of form of
government that's a great question and
um I think the answer the appropriate
answer is no because official ballot is
not a form of government but a process
of
government uh and is addressed in other
you other questions for Mr Frost I see
none thank you very much for your
testimony
Grace thank you Mr chair um I guess I'll
answer specific uh n Grace for the
municipal Association we do uh support
this legislation um the committee had a
number of specific questions that I will
uh attempt to answer um representative
power and Howland had some questions
about um
recision uh for the provisions related
to um local option for the select board
to uh to change
zoning um while I do agree with with Mr
Frost um I I will note as I'm sure
representative power is aware that there
are some statutes that have very
specific um questions written out those
include uh statutes like 404 Roman
um seven uh as well and similar and then
there are some that aren't so specific
like 31 95b and which just basically say
they can resend in the same manner um my
I generally agree with Mr Frost that if
there's no specific provision in the
statutes you could just have another
warrant article that would be voted on
to resend to that
power
um representative award um had a
question about um the form of of
government uh again I would agree with
Mr Frost that um Bas in either the SP
SP2 form or SP2 or non sb2 towns you'd
still have it what is called a town
meeting um I agree uh with
representative Alward that that could be
clarified um further but I'm not sure
that's strictly
necessary um representative Brown had a
question about parking um and the use of
that uh I would I would mention that I
think that the uh the intent here um of
the parking process is a better option
than a strict mandate for the number of
parking spots that may be allowed for
any residential
use uh and the reason for that is that
we know that there are many scenar iOS
where residential uses are not
traditional um so they are you know in
older areas of a municipality there may
be very limited parking options newer
they may have surface Lots they may have
um you know mixed use Etc all of those
will require different demands for
parking um those are very specific uh
and so rather than a uh legislative
mandate from conquered a local uh local
adopted Provisions that are tailored to
the town make more sense um and in that
case uh what is proposed here and the
intent of what is proposed here is that
that can still occur but um if the
applicant says Hey the particular use
that I'm proposing is in some way um
going to be addressed by the number of
parking spots I want to propose Which is
less than the minimum and I can prove
that then that has to be considered by
the local board they have to weigh the
evidence there they have the option of
going to a a third party for review um
and then the intent is although it's not
expressly written out here that that
third party review will help lead them
to decide whether it is appropriate or
not appropriate to um to uh grant that
waiver of the minimum parking
requirements and that's a I think that's
a better option than any
other policy options we might have
because as Mr Frost said parking is very
complicated and so it makes sense to
tailor that to the specific municipality
at the municipality level happy to take
any questions that the committee may
have representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question with regards
to the type of development that's
um the subject matter of section um two
and and three and that is um office
industrial or
commercial is it true that this these
types of development projects can
already be done
um right now with maybe um waivers from
the zba and that of course the tax
relief piece would not be
there yes those development projects can
already be done I think the only
question is whe whether there can be a
local tax relief incentive and that's
the intent here um I'll note um as I'm
sure you've noted representative power
that um repeated in sections 2 and three
it says office use I think the intent is
to incorporate what's in section A which
is office industrial or commercial and
oversight represent
majori thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question Mr Grace um I
I've heard now a couple of times um with
the parking requirements and I'm going
to page three and I'm going to line
25 uh that if the applicant can uh
demonstrate that he has a solution that
the that the planning board should
consider that
solution am I correct that the language
says that the planning board shall
accept and approve or shall approve the
alternate yes so that if the applicant
demonstrates that the alternate is um
the a VI is the viable solution then the
planning board has to has to cons has to
agree and adopt that and would it would
be a mandatory waiver of the minimum
M further
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Will
Stewart I'm the executive director of
stay work play New Hampshire which if
you're not familiar with it is a
Statewide nonprofit whose mission is the
attraction and retention of young people
here in the granite state and housing is
the number one issue facing young people
here it's what's preventing them from
staying here it's what's preventing them
from moving here
um there's not enough and what exists is
not affordable enough so as such you
know stay workk play is in full support
of SB 538 and encourage its passage um
we want to see more housing built that's
more affordable to more young people
happy to answer any questions uh I would
also refer you to stay Workplay dorg uh
where you can find results of stay
workpl 2023 survey of young people in
New Hampshire uh which was conducted Ed
by the St anel Survey Center and the
results of stay work plays recent policy
and pint Series where we went all around
the state talking to young people and in
both of these cases housing was you know
loud and clear again the number one
issue contributing to the cost of living
challenges for young people here in New
Hampshire which we desperately need
which our employers need which our
cities and towns need which our
nonprofits need to do all the work that
we need done here in New Hampshire thank
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um looking at the
sections that discuss the tax relief in
incentive so of course
initially the the cost for such housing
will be at a certain price point then
later in the future when these tax
reliefs
expire what what's going to happen to
the
the the cost for such housing now that
the the
tax the taxable property is is going to
be increased so there's going to
be you understand my question sure and
I'll caveat my response by saying that
uh at stay work play you know we are not
a housing uh or tax policy organization
so I might if I can you know defer any
responses uh or refer them you know to
my colleagues you who are here behind me
um you know I will just reiterate that
state work play as uh as an organization
that aims to attract and retain more
young people and does nonpartisan issues
based advocacy like this are here in
support of this bill you know as we see
it you know through its multitude of of
facets you know as contributing to you
know making housing more affordable in
housing further questions seeing none
thank you for your testimony uh next
Harrison
canor excuse me hello um thank you
honorable chair and committee for
hearing from me today my name is
Harrison kler I'm the executive director
of affordable housing education and
development we are a community housing
development organization registered with
HUD we serve in uh Northern grafting
County and Coos County doing development
of affordable Workforce housing in that
region as well as Community Development
efforts up there uh I also serve on the
governing Council for housing action New
Hampshire which uh is a advocacy group
uh in favor of affordable housing I'm
also a member of the governor's Council
on housing stability uh and I was also
uh state representative for Carol County
what is I believe now district one in
2019 and 2020 um so I thank you for
hearing from me I uh I'm in we're ahead
is in support of um this bill think it
brings a lot of great things to the
table um I I cannot speak as eloquently
or technically to it as uh those who
already have so I will try to keep my
piece
brief um we use 790 a lot of the
communities in the North Country rely on
790 um you know we look at work we're
doing in Whitefield in Berlin uh
Lancaster colbrook these are all towns
that uh previously had quite a lot of
economic uh commercial industrial
activity and no longer do and some of
those buildings are starting to turn to
blight this is an opportunity for those
communities to see those buildings
repurposed and reused um to the needs of
the community so uh we we already make
use of it we work in municipalities who
do and this gives them even more even
more leeway as far as whether or not
they want to adopt it um to give us an
incentive to come in and work with them
um an another piece that obviously uh is
is great is the the parking piece and I
will actually come with uh my experience
I was previously the executive director
for um Mount Washington Valley Housing
Coalition and I worked with a lot of
planning boards throughout the Mount
Washington Valley working on their codes
and updating them and I think another
piece that we often forget about is that
we have a lot of our um zoning boards
especially in our rural communities are
completely volunteers um they are not
trained in planning they are not trained
in zoning um and they struggle to find
out what they can do to best help and
serve their communities and a lot of
them just need to know a place to start
and so legislation like this can help
Point them in their efforts in the right
direction to say we have highlighted
parking as being a huge issue and now
you can uh augment Your Capacity by
having different groups bring
alternative parking proposals to you so
that you can look at what works for your
community based on those proposals and
make adequate changes um that are going
to help better serve your communities in
the long run so I think that's an an
added bonus again for a lot of our rural
communities um
lastly um lastly I just talk about the
um increased ability for select boards
um I did also just serve as a
commissioner on Conway's Town Charter
commission um we got over 50% but didn't
hit 60% unfortunately and um one of the
things that we were looking at is the
limited ability of our select board um
Conway has an immense amount of
development going on right now and one
of the things we were considering was
that we would have to completely change
our Charter to a Town Council in order
to give the council then an ability to
act um in more than a regular annual
fashion on getting any sort of zoning
changes done um so we uh unfortunately
weren't able to get that because there
was a lot of con concern generally about
going to a Town Council and sort of a
select board but being able to maintain
our select board and sb2 form of
government while still being able to
increase the abilities of the select
board would be an added advantage to
many communities in the state because I
I believe from a presentation actually
given by uh Mr Grace that I I believe
the select board is the number one uh
form of government in the state of New
Hampshire so there are many
municipalities who would be able to take
advantage of that um so again fully
support this um happy to answer any
questions that I can and thank you for
your
time thank you forther questions
representative power thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so I'm I'm going to go back to
the question that I asked the prime
sponsor with regards to the involvement
of the planning board in just that cycle
of researching and you know wording or
zoning ordinances and and
such I I'm hearing testimony that this
part of the bill that provision is going
to enable more frequent
adoption of
ordinances but yet at the same time I
still see that natural cycle that
natural I guess you know process by
which the planning board is going to
engage in so while I hear on one hand
what um people are saying in testimony
as to why this provision in the bill is
good I'm just there's some disconnect
can you help me to to understand that um
I again I can't speak to it probably as
technically as others but the way I
would Envision it is a kind of a
systemic shift so the reason that the
planning boards operate kind of on the
timeline they do presently in
communities where they just have an
annual meeting is because they just have
the annual meeting so as a result they
have to kind of be studying researching
preparing for that one given date um if
you then have a new system wherein they
can be essentially doing that throughout
the entire year knowing that when it
hits the next body after they've
approved it they support it and they
want to move it forward and it can then
go to the next board and they can after
hearing that presentation decide to
adopt it it's not necessarily tied to
that one static date and is more on a
moving timeline that gives them the
ability to be reviewing these things on
a more regular
basis would would be how would interpret
that further
questions I see none thank you for your
testimony thank you very much yep uh
last pink card I have if anybody else is
intending to speak I don't have your
chette thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is Dave
juv I'm a senior vice president for the
business and industry Association not
before this committee all that much I
want to take a moment to uh let you know
what the Bia is we serve as New
Hampshire Statewide Chamber of Commerce
we have approximately 400 employer
members that go from the largest
businesses in the state down to single
uh sole
proprietorships Alto together our
members employ over 100,000 Grand Granit
Staters I'm here to convey um again the
importance of the availability and
affordability of housing in the working
uh in New Hampshire um our members and
I'm sure if you were to talk to
Employers in your districts uh they
would tell you that housing has a direct
impact on their ability to hire people
and retain workers and Workforce
availability is by far the number one
employer concern in New Hampshire now
and it has been for the last four or
five years so we strongly support this
bill it's one of uh many different
housing related bills that Bia is uh
supporting this session including yours
Mr uh chairman turot uh so I hope the uh
committee will look favorably on it um
as the sponsor and other Advocates have
said if there are issues that you think
need additional work and review we are
all happy to work with the committee to
come up with something that everybody
can agree on that concludes my testimony
Mr chair I'm happy to answer any
questions with the caveat that there are
more people far more knowledgeable than
me on the uh nuts and bolts of the
legislation very good
questions I see none you're off the hook
thank you all right okay with that um I
don't have any more pink cards so we
will go ahead and we did have the blue
signing sheet with two individuals
signing
in favor and one of them spoke here so
with that we'll close the hearing on H
uh SP 538 and our
next hearing will be at 10:30 so you
Mr
juv I just would like to now that the
hearing is over I would correct you that
bill
e
everybody
Senator jendro have you filled out a
pink card I'm assuming you're
introducing I think you filled it out as
538 rather than 448 the bill
you yeah it says 538 on it I'll correct
good okay good morning anyone everyone
we're going to get going here uh opening
the hearing on SP 448 relative to the
Woodsville fire district Senator jendro
is the prime sponsor and she is here to
introduce and discuss her bill you have
good morning chair and members of the
municipal and County government
committee I am Senator Carrie gendro
representing district one just a little
history um on this bill there is a lot
of history but just a little bit of
history for many years the town of havil
in the precinct or Village District of
Woodsville have been somewhat at odds as
to what is fair and Equitable there have
been many iterations of changes to these
bills over the years when I presented
this bill to the election law and
Municipal Affairs committee Senator gray
wanted to settle this as he said once
and for all the committee and the sen
and Senator gray work diligently to
create fairness for both parties
currently the Reliance of funding going
to a war article is not working havil
has the ability to tax all the people in
the village District Village districts
pay that tax Woodsville wants to have
their own fire and Highway departments
there are three other Village District
or precincts in hail and none of them
have been in front of the election law
and Municipal Affairs committee over the
years the New Hampshire Department of re
Revenue Administration has been um
involved in the loop of this so Senate
Bill 448 FN as amended establishes the
Woodsville fire district as a village
district with all rights duties and
obligations of such a district governed
by RSA 52 due to continued division over
finances between Woodsville and hail a
contingency formula has been created
this formula will be used to calculate
reimbursement of Woodsville for taxes
collected by havil the passage of this
legislation will provide improved
Clarity of procedures for both The
Village district and the town so
basically what Senator gray wanted to
set up was something that neither side
necessarily totally won or totally lost
he wanted to set it up so it was a 5050
win um he did go to the town of
Woodsville hayil to meet with both
groups and he's kind of left it where he
would like for them to sit down come to
an agreement because it really shouldn't
be the legislature that determines the
outcome of this so this is where it's at
now if it sounds like a mess it it
probably
is so um I do thank you for your
consideration for o for ought to pass
for Senate Bill 448 FN I know there are
people here that will testify I do have
to get back to my committee but I'm
happy to take um any
questions thank for Testimony
representative power thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
Senator as as You' stated this is a very
complex issue and and I understand what
the bill seeks to do but for me in order
to make um a
just decision with regarding this
legislation it's important for me to
understand you know the foundational the
basics and I'm I'm very confused I did I
did a lot of research there's a lot of
information out there and I was trying
to understand first and foremost you're
the subject of this legislation is the
Woodsville fire district yet in my
research so I understand what a fire
district is to to me it it's a village
District that was established for the
purpose of um dealing with um fire
concerns but I heard you say in your
testimony that the town of
Woodsville and I've also heard ascertain
that that type of a I guess a a
mentality with regarding to Woodsville
fire district or Woodsville Village or
whatever you want to call it is is it a
town is is it a village district and
that's confusing to me because to me I
see Woodsville fire district and I even
went and and did research and obtained
the
um the statute the the laws from 1899
and I think it was
1913 trying to understand what is
Woodsville can can you help me to
understand that
hopefully and if I can and I know there
are people here that that can there are
four precincts or Village districts in
the town of hail and it was described to
me it's it's like you've got a a sheet
of paper and on top of it you've got
four Post-it notes the the paper itself
is the township of havil but the Post-it
notes are the precincts well Woodsville
is one of those
precincts and and to their credit they I
would have to say that they are the
business Hub of havil there's Walmarts
there there are a lot of restaurants a
lot of businesses that are and back in
the day when the railroad was going
through that was the place to go so I
understand you know the them wanting to
um preserve that and as as they should
because they are the the business Hub if
you had to look at it in the the
entirety of of
hail I don't know if that I'm starting
to answer your question or not but it's
that's why I say it's it is very
confusing it's not they're they're not a
town hail is the town but they are a
village District or
Precinct go
ahead thank you Mr chairman I just have
a quick followup so that you did mention
in your in your bill introduction that
part of this bill is to establish
Woodsville fire district as a village
District but is not Woodsville fire
district already a village District part
of it is the finan
renum
ruination well whatever getting money
back so it's um that was part of the
concern was the um and and again I'm not
sure I fully comprehend the formula um I
I just keep going back to what is fair
um for both the town of hail and the
representative priest go ahead thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question is fire fire and Highway
Maintenance a problem for
Woodside um actually they've got eight
miles of Highway in the precinct or the
village of
Woodsville um it it's no I I would say
no it's not a problem they've done a
departments represent
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question um I know
this issue went before The Supreme Court
can you tell us what the Supreme Court
how the Supreme Court feels about this
case I I can't but I know that there are
people behind me that would be able to
let you know you're welcome thank you
repres
gallager uh so I was looking through my
uh past notes about uh previous bills
relating to to the whole Woodsville
situation that we've heard while I've
while I was here um first was sb26 in uh
2021 which was through Public Works and
Highway which um modified
um the I see there's also Highway
portion in this build too and then um
and then there was also s SP 239 in
2022 which had to do um with
audit requirements so um does this
bill
um how how does this bill relate to
those previous pieces of legislation
does it
um does it undo or go um the previous
bills or go farther in those directions
or um yeah how does it relate that's a
that's a good question um couple good
question questions there if this this
bill is to make it fair and Equitable
for both the precinct and the
town that was the intention of
it so does it eliminate both of the
other bills no the the intention is
that Senator gray um wanted to make sure
that with this bill that it was the last
bill that comes before the legislature
so to make it as fair and Equitable for
both now both the precinct and the
township of Hil still have the ability
agreement thank you Mr chairman and
thank you senator for taking my question
you mentioned and I I appreciate your
explanation of the overall town of hail
and the four different pre precincts
Woodsville being just one of them the
other three precincts are they
established already to the way that
Woodsville wants to be or are they kind
of just hanging out there they have um
yeah I mean they're established and
they're they're hanging out one one
other Precinct is called the Mountain
Lakes um Precinct uh which it's like a
resort well people live there year round
but they have their own little um uh
there's a lake there and but they they
are an established Precinct as well as
Pike and I believe it's havil corner is
the the third so Woodsville and and
again going back to credit for
Woodsville they are probably the
business Hub of the township of havil
follow up Mr chairman now the town of
hail itself does it have fire protection
yes
and currently is there responsibility
the entire
town for the right correct correct and
Woodsville is responsible for their
eight miles now I could stand corrected
on this because I'm not sure of all the
intricacies because I do know Woodsville
has eight miles of road that they're
responsible
for thank you representative
savis thank you Mr chair and thank you
senator for taking my question um I'm
intrigued by what you said about um
Senator gray I think his intention to
have this be the last bill that comes
before the legislature on this topic but
yet this committee gets bills in every
term on Village districts in one way
shape or form or another so I doubt that
this will be the last one however um
what we typically do not get are
proposed bills that lay out special
formulas for funding for individual
Village
districts my question for you is are you
concerned that by putting into statute
something that affects kind of the
nitty-gritty running of one Village
District might have unintended
consequences of all the other Village
districts in the state well that's a
very real concern
yes further questions
seeing none thank you senator for your
testimony thank you yes sir uh next up
representative
lad good morning Mr chairman members of
the uh Municipal uh uh committee here
first time I've had an opportunity to
speak here with Municipal this year uh
so I appreciate this opportunity um
although I have been the uh selectboard
chair of the town of havil a number of
years I've been on their planning board
I've been on their zoning board and I
have been their representative since
2008 so I'd like to give you a little
bit of history about the community I
live in and then go through the history
of what we have here in terms of uh
legislation uh that I first got involved
with back in 2008 with uh Senator r
represent iner britson and myself uh I
forgot to mention anybody who comes up
to testify we know on the pink glad hail
graft and five good but I'd also want to
know whether you're for or against the
bill I oppose the Bill thank you I
oppose the bill okay going back we have
yes we we are a town that has a lot of
roots in it in terms of going back over
the years back to
1763 um four districts Mountain Lakes
Woodsville North havil and havil Corner
which we call
havil years ago when there was a a road
coming up from the conquered area it
went to havil havil corner now that's
where you have the common it's also
where Dartmouth College wanted to plant
its College initially but they chose in
the end to go down to
Hanover so hail is the southern uh
District that's on the uh border with
permont havil has their own three
Commissioners havil Corner Commissioners
and they are in charge their Water
Commission I was also chair of that
commission for a number of years uh we
had our own fire department since then
the fire department has merged in with
the town of havil under a lot of angst
going north to North havil North havil
also has their own water department they
also have their own their their fire
Department which is now part of the
Town Mountain Lakes does not have a fire
department Mountain Lakes was initially
a private
corporation that was uh which has a
sizable a with the lake as described by
uh the senator uh it was a community
which went bankrupt though and the town
had to take it all over and there's
roads going up and down the hills and
all over the place and there's boundary
uh uh uh question marks as far as far as
whether you're on Town property or on
Precinct property or you own property
reminds me when I lived in Alaska we
didn't know where the state owned land
where the town own land or where the
native corporations own land then we
have Woodsville Woodsville is a
community which has its own fire
department all our emergency services
for ambulance service come out of
Woodsville they have their own sewer
department they have their own roads and
they have their own power they generate
Hydro
power it is the Hub of our community in
terms of retail businesses there are
business elsewhere but that's where our
assessed property values lay in
Woodsville now when we are looking at
this
community it's it's a a community has a
lot of Deep Roots and a lot of cultural
background and the the community of of
Woodsville that fire district resp is
responsible for fire in that particular
District but they're also part of Twin
State Mutual Aid and so they have
agreements they will work with fire
departments all through the area when I
first got on the select board we had
these four districts but we also had
outlayer areas within havil which were
called havil which didn't pay any fire
tax money at
all the individual districts had their
own fire departments other than Mountain
Lakes and they were taxing for their
those fire departments to serve there
but also they had Twin State Mutual Aid
where they worked out just provide
services to all of havil but the people
in the other areas of havil weren't
paying any fire money so when I chaired
the select board we went together as the
all of them together uh all members of
the select board and the Commissioners
together and we decided it was only fair
that everybody in the whole area of hav
pay for fire Services we did that we
came together and agreed upon let's move
and consolidate and get together and
that's what we were in the process of
doing back in 2009 as I mentioned
earlier under Senate Bill
75 when I first came in in 2008 and
2009 Senator Reynolds myself and
representative iner britson got together
and developed a
formula and the formula had previously
been done by Paul Lamont back in the
1990s representative Lamont we updated
that formula I have a copy of that
formula right here that formula was
unanimously agreed upon by the
Commissioners in Woodsville and the
select board we came together and agreed
this is where we want to be un unanimous
amongst all people in the community it
was local control the way local control
should be
done since then we've had some conflict
and we've changed Town
managers just recently we've changed our
form of government this last town
meeting from town manager form of
government to Town Administrator form of
government the chair of the select board
has
resigned the road agent for havil has
resigned we have conflict up there the
finance administrator
is gone the town of hail is in flux
right
now the District of Woodsville is
not we have a court case going on right
now which I believe we need to let that
case resolve itself and determine where
we're going to go with all this business
upon a decision being made by the court
system not prior to and not as a result
of this bill or any other effort that
was Prior made to this
now what we have is a bill that's coming
forward that does not have the support
of the
Commissioners we're not working together
we're just splitting this town apart and
believe me we are splitting it apart
havil years back is it's in a
Cooperative School District we had a
Academy down in havil corner and up
later on when that closed down we went
to Woodsville there was a lot of angst
there oh we don't want our kids going up
to Woodsville we want them down in havil
we got over that and we got through it
but that old wound is surfacing again as
a result of this legislation and
legislation we've had in past years I
suggest that we need to back off and
recognize back in
1885 statute Was Made Back Then
designing the capability for Woodsville
to have their Highway Department the
fire and to act as a
municipality but there's still a Village
District what the town of havil provides
from the town offices is our police
force and we have a very very large
police
force you know approximating around
eight officers then we have the County
Complex located there so we have the
sheriff's department there and we have
state troopers there as well so we have
a lot of good protection but we have to
look at this this issue right here I
don't think it's the right time for us
to be moving something like this forward
quite truthfully either we back it off
to what represent our Senator Reynolds
and Paul erson and myself decided back
in uh the year um uh 2009 and I have
that legislation right here which your
bill could be amended quite easily put
that in where it's the there's a formula
for how we divide the money up the money
is collected by the town yes but then
how is it distributed down to support
the highway department in Woodsville
Woodsville has their own sidewalk walks
their own sewer system running along the
side of the road all the roads are paved
much different some the gravel roads
which are out in
hail and they've done a tremendous job
of maintaining those
roads we also have you know the all the
Lighting systems you know the you know
those red yellow and green things we
have to stop for they're in ha in in
Woodsville so in conclusion I'd like to
say that we have a system that's working
but we don't have what's working
is working together amongst our
commissioners in Woodsville and the
select board itself hopefully some
changes will be made the Woodsville
Commissioners have come to the town
often say let's sit down and talk about
this oh we can't talk about this because
it's in the court system right now and
we can't talk and that's what so that's
what's going on it's time for us to slow
down as a legislature let's this thing
hammer out quite frankly either itl this
thing or interum study it but to move it
forward it's going to cause more
conflict and we're going to have another
Community that's just uh inflames and by
the way Pike is not a district pike pike
is an area they used to have a water
system that's been closed down there
only were 15 people on that water system
um so I and one other thing it was
declared that Woodsville had to go
through and do an audit they've done all
the audits they came out clean at one
point in time the legislature or
representatives from the other side of
the wall were saying we need a forensic
audit done of
Woodsville no no that's not what's
needed and the audits have come out by
Department of Revenue Administration
saying everything is clean in fact audit
all the audits have been done by
Woodsville even before the town audit
got
done so so that's where I stand Mr chair
it's a I think we get where you are it's
questions representative
power thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question so
I'll ask you the same question that I
asked the prime sponsor and it's with
regards to what is Woodsville so my
understanding that I see that it's
Woodsville fire district and
my my belief is that it's a village
district for the purpose of
extinguishing fires and I I also think
that I understand that part of that
Village District function also has to do
with
roads so again I'm confused
because based on like I said before the
research that I've done some people
think that Woodsville is a town when
it's really not it's a village District
do you see this as part of the confus
correct it has powers to to raise
inappropriate taxes for the purposes of
which it was formed which I'm assuming
it's the fire district the fire district
but it's a village District which has
the authority by Statute to have their
own Highway Department their own Road
agent uh it goes beyond what the what
and there are the the administrator for
that district is sitting behind me and I
think you best asked Mr Shelton that
you representative
Gallagher um
so about the part where you said that um
every audit of Woodsville has uh come
back clean in the past as I was
reviewing my notes from the past bills
we had and um apparently part of the
reason we had um SB
um s SB uh the previous bills I
mentioned was because that Woodsville
had failed in audit so um are are are my
notes wrong on that I think if you're
talking about s
sp25 uh sb75 came prior to that that is
what was said but there's no factual
information to back any of that up when
the audits were completed and you can
ask the people that were audited they're
sitting behind me there is no uh
forensic audit needed and the audits
were done as as all of you know that
there's a lot of towns in this state
which are small towns and they did
things years ago the way the good old
boys may have done it and they put the
in the till right here and they took the
money out and they co-mingled monies but
it wasn't done with any purpose for you
know for a forensic type issue so I can
go to all the towns I I Haver itself's
probably done that Pont have done that
they all had done
that further
questions representative
Guthrie thank you thank you Mr chair and
thank you for coming and testifying
I I come from a
town uh and I really don't understand
the structure that you have in the havil
area can you tell me why at any time
they did not in even consider
incorporating all the areas that are in
dispute into one town we were working in
that direction in terms of fire Services
when we combined into one budget and we
also put a committee together which
looked at all our capital equipment our
Rolling Stock in terms of fire havil had
more equipment at that time than the
town of Littleton
had and so when we purchase new
equipment now it has to go for that
committee and we make sure that it's
what the North or the South End of the
Town need do we need something that's
going to be a water truck do we need a
ladder truck um so we're we're working
towards that end and that was the
direction we were going at but then all
of a sudden the state got
involved and it all fell apart
and we weren't talking with each other
and with that I think we need to get
back to that this is a it's much like
Conway was at one point in time Conway
had all the different little districts
were there but we are dealing with a
very unique situation in Woodsville and
I my family goes back in fact eight
Generations nine Generations ago my
grandfather was one who founded the town
of
havil and so there's a lot of history
there um it's wonderful place to live
when we did our survey of updating where
we were our master plan people came
there because they love the quality of
life they love the relationship we have
to the land and they love the nature of
the farming Community but they also love
the nature of what we have in Woodsville
so um it's Unique we don't have any
public libraries we all have private
libraries I think you answered the
question initially thank you yeah
further questions seeing none very thank
you very much for your testim thank you
very much um just for the the remainder
of the individuals uh if you have new
information please do um give it in your
testimony I'd ask that you please do not
repeat we are past uh well we will be
well past our our schedule uh just so we
all know out there U Miss NATO we're
going to save you for the end so you can
Shelton good
morning good morning thank you honorable
representatives for allowing me to speak
I'm Kevin Shelton I am the administrator
for the Woodsville fire district I've
been there for four and a half years
now um I appreciate the work that the
Senate has done
and the investment that you folks more
than likely will put into this uh but I
feel um I'm in opposition of it because
I feel it still needs some
work um I the question was asked uh what
is Woodsville and I try to answer that
now um it was it was formed in 1885 to
extinguish
fires um and I believe it was school
district number four was its footprint
because I've gone back and and read that
um its purposes have been expanded over
the
years
Corporation um you know since its
foundation it's always had a highway and
fire
department um and as somebody stated
earlier uh it is the economic Center of
of of Woodsville of town of havil um and
there isn't a week that goes by that
somebody doesn't say why don't we stop
fighting why don't we turn into our own
town you know and become the town of
Woodsville so so there is that
um that uh belief or or want in in in
the area to to just have Woodsville go
its own ways um however uh these Special
Districts they they all serve many
purposes um in addition to what Rick
said Woodsville is about we have
sidewalks we have street lights um you
know the the village Village members all
of them um you know
appreciate all of those
um over the last 100 years Woodsville
has always received back a proportionate
share of the Town Highway budget
um in 2019 there was a new town manager
and the formula that was in place um was
contested and it's it led to several
years of litigation which Woodsville
ultimately um the court decided in in
its
favor that brought about additional
legislation in 21 which took out the
funding formula and it left it left uh
it basically up to the voters by means
of uh a warant article petitioned
article at at the annual meeting for the
voters to
decide um the first year that occurred U
it was passed and funding came to
Woodsville or or was approved it was
contested at by the town and the
Department of Revenue that it wasn't
legal and that is what is before The
Supreme Court right now there that
hearing was in January and they uh they
said it would be six to nine months
before the outcome of that would would
be
heard
um so Woodsville population represents
about 25% of the town of havil and we
represent about
22.75% of the tax
base
um we have two suggestions on a
compromise that we would ask you to
consider if if this isn't um tabled or
put aside and and those would be to add
back in capital projects to the highway
formula um it can be a big part of the
highway budget for the town of havil and
it would that big part would be funded
proportionally by by Woodsville um and
the second is to calculate the fire
funding formula on a per capita basis
questions representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question and I'd like
to um for you to clarify something for
2021 there there was a there was a bill
to remove the funding formula from
statute and I believe that was Senate
Bill 26
so I'm assuming that was signed into law
and
so previously there was a funding
formula in statute it was
removed could you explain to me the pro
you said a warrant article and
then I just have one comment after that
so now what's before us is another bill
to put the funding formula back into
statute so just yes or no on that and
then
explain the what it looks like with
regards to the funding by warrant
articles explain that in Greater detail
okay uh the first part uh yes the the
the it took out the funding formula it
made it only available by petitioned
articles approved by the voters at the
annual meeting so to me that took it out
of the back room with six guys making
the decision and put it before the the
public the problem with that is it could
be all or nothing or something in
between the the challenge with the
current language and why I've asked for
consideration for uh compromise or or
amending that is that the threshold is
too low um From woodville's
perspective and there would be no
incentive for a to come to the table and
negotiate a different
[Music]
agreement did I follow up thank you Mr
chairman so to be clear is am I
understanding it properly that this you
said petitioned Warren article so that
that's obviously that's the citizens it
wouldn't be the Commissioners put of the
village District putting this forward
it's citizens getting together drafting
an article putting it on the warrant and
it's so this petition warrant article is
in
Woodsville the residents of the
Woodsville fire district no no um it it
is at the town's annual meeting is where
that formulation would would
be so it it would be the residents of
the town of havil asking the taxpayers
pres of Guth thank you Mr chair and
thank you for your testimony I just to
get a concept of what we're dealing with
here I understand there's three other
areas there there's the haval city to
the town of havil and uh the main
area that's within the town of havil
then there's three other districts how
how involved are they in this dispute if
you will
uh they're on the
sidelines um and and I don't think any
of them are ready to give up their
Special Districts uh we we actually are
working together uh all all four
commissions on on a water a potential
Water Project right now so so we we we
communicate we see each other but they
each district feels it it has a purpose
and a valid purpose uh for its
constituents
thank you representative
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
um to be blunt this feels like a rabbit
hole to me uh this legislature and this
committee within this legislature is
about setting up structures and systems
of
individual divisions of government work
out their budg issues and work out their
personnel issues is up to them to
resolve what is it about this issue that
resolve I My Hope Is that um the the
formula as as it's written can can be
one that both sides can agree
on and without that there there
Bill further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony oh representative
GTH sorry Mr chairman but thank you for
the recognizing me I it just happened to
uh come into my head is how
I it sounds like you're able to okay
I'll ask ask the question question is if
this bill would be passed would that
bring all parties together or would it
cause more of a problem than it that
already
exists sir I I don't believe this would
pull everyone together this formul as as
I see it um and have run the numbers
would provide
uh
Woodsville uh roughly
$150,000 a year towards the highway
budget the highway budget we expend over
300,000 and and frankly the last four
years it has just been getting by so
we've done no zero capital projects and
highways so that
number's uh going to be a lot lot higher
than that and I think passing this
ultimately would put or could Woodsville
out of the the the road business our
taxes are exceptionally High you know
most of that is centered around
um education as you all know but um add
the town tax in and then the precinct
tax which is roughly
$9,000 without doing anything um and in
Highway being currently five5 or $6 doar
of that in round numbers I think it puts
is out of the highway business the
voters will decide ultimately whether
they can afford it or not but that's
where this would put put things without
resolve followup Mr chair so is it fair
to say that uh followup go ahead thank
you uh is it fair to say uh that this
bill would not act as a uh a catalyst to
get it because my understanding is right
now the the side how many sides there
are are not really talking anymore
that's they walk away from the table if
that's the case will this bring them
back and act as a catalyst or will it
just I've testified I don't believe that
there's any incentive from the other
side to to want to negotiate further
with the way this is written right thank
you very much thank you Mr
chair further questions all right seeing
none thank you for your testimony and
good morning I'm stepen will and thank
you for letting me testify in front of
this
committee um I've lived in Woodsville
for over 50 years since I come home from
Vietnam I
um this bill will definitely kill the
highway in
Woodsville it doesn't give us any
anywhere near enough I'm the chair of
the commission up
there uh we've tried to sit down we've
given them more opportunities we sent in
letters they don't they aren't going to
communicate with us because this bill's
in their
favor uh it's just it's just killing us
and besides this
bill the town receives 1 million
$15,000 in vehicle registrations every
year we've comped Ed that a third of
those are in Woodsville we don't get any
receipts from that also rooms and meals
$45,000 a year in rooms and meals
Woodsville gets zero and all the
restaurants and then grocery stores the
Super Walmart they're all in Woodsville
there's nothing
else the block grant money they get
$175,000 a year for the roadblock grant
money the last three years we've got
zero
the Opera block and the other
um HUD
housing it getes about $43,000 a year
they're all in Woodsville we don't get
any money from
that the population in Woodsville is
12200 people we have to supply a ladder
truck because of the Opera block the
town has no ladder truck we have to
because it's three stories according to
the rules and regulations of Fire
Systems we have to supply a lot of truck
the town doesn't have one a lot of
trucks over a million
dollars the town is never bought any of
our fire equipment we've bought all of
our own fire equipment all of our own
road equipment we've had been in the
road business since
1885 because Woodsville was the center
of the railroad companies and the we had
four different railroads coming through
Woodsville in 1885 so we had to set up
sewer systems we had to set up Road
systems side walks there's no sidewalks
in any other buy we have the curbs on
the road we don't even know who owns
them but if it's a town or if the town
takes over our roads or if it's a
sidewalks because of the carbon
system it doesn't it's it's just killing
me and the high school is in Woodsville
it sets up on a hill if they don't plow
the roads early enough and they don't
plow their roads as early as we do they
won't have any school that day cuz Hill
goes both ways to get up to that High
School the hospital's in the middle of a
big hill I live just up beyond the
hospital but when the town used to have
that road before they turned it over to
Woodsville there was many days we
couldn't get home unless you had a
four-wheel drive pickup because the town
didn't have it plowed and now they built
another complex that's a uh another
Surgical Center across from the hospital
the cars pull out you can't
stop they pull out in front of you you
can't can't stop going down that Hill
it's so slippery uh it it's just a
disaster this bill was just going to
kill it and by passing this bill the way
it's
written is there's no incentive for the
select board in the town to come and
talk to us because they're getting out
of it Britney of Scott Frey as Kevin
just explained to you uh we can't live
on that they'll be in the Town Road
business and there's no way they can do
it for what we're doing it for they say
8 Miles well you know when you plow a
road that doubles cuz you got to go both
ways on that road to plow it so it's
actually 16 mies and if you look at all
the rest of the state as the Dr pointed
out Town's the size of Woodsville are
between $30 and $50 per square mile to
do the roads because of the way they're
constructed a t a town dirt road isn't
like
that this formula that's on this thing
is based on the road Road M monies all
representative lalis I saw your hand
up thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for being
here put me
down for appreciating your service to
your country and your impassioned
testimony thank
you thank you I'm a fully disabled
veteran myself representative FR thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my my
question um in listening to your
testimony and the testimony of others
that preceded
you um I think it's fair to say that
there is a lot of emotion and
animosity between the parties my
question
um when the Supreme Court hands down its
ruling whichever way the ruling goes do
you feel that the parties are willing to
accept that ruling or will the animosity
continue I think it depends on which way
it
goes I really do because uh we had the
same thing as Rick lad said back in uh
1969 with the schools when they
Consolidated Schools havil didn't want
to give up their school but they wanted
to come to Woodsville high school so we
did a
a Cooper Cooperative school district and
over the years it's it's cooled down but
uh this this whole thing I don't know if
it'll ever cool down and like I say I've
years
the sentive power thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question sir
I appreciate your um testimony here
today so
my understanding is that the Woodsville
fire district is a village district and
in statute we have 14 distinct purposes
for which a village District can be
formed um my understanding is that you
are the commissioner of the Woodsville
fire distri district and I keep asking
the same question so I hope that you can
help to set the record straight for me
in my head could you please tell me for
what purposes what 14
purposes is the Woodsville fire district
established for it was for for for water
and Roads and today in 2024 it's just
for those two distinct separate purposes
that's what water and Roads that's what
the precinct is but we also have
Woodsville water and lights which is
half of it and we also have an ambulance
service we have the only sewer system in
town which goes down to the county and
down to the towns industrial park in
North
ail thank thank you forther
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank you uh
yes my name is Robert a
massini uh my history in the town of
havil is I served on the uh planning
board for around 20 years The havil
Cooperative school board for 18 years
and the havil select board for around
nine
years in all that
time we've always been able to handle
our own
problems
and for some reason the uh State's
formula to provide
uh the roadways and Woodsville uh worked
uh for over 130 years but uh when the
new town manager came in I guess we
discontinued that uh formula and
everything's been in turmoil in the town
of havil and Woodsville fire district
ever
since also I didn't say my address is uh
40 slave rid in uh havil corner I don't
live in
Woodsville so I'm opposed to the bill is
as stands right now because it doesn't
provide
even level funding for what the cost of
the roads in the fire department
Woodville would
be and and I remember in one of the
Senate hearings the Bureau of Revenue
Administration testified about uh four
five or six communities similar to
Woodville and what their per mileage
cost would be and it vared from 20 odd
th000 a mile to 50 odd th000 a mile
average probably being someplace in the
30s which comes closer to what
uh what is costing Woods
and again we always were able to handle
things within the town itself for years
and years and like I said the select
board and the Commissioners got together
and came up with a formula to fund the
fire departments well since three or
four years
ago the town of havil doesn't fund wood
fire department uh they they don't uh
put a doar forward yet the village of
Woodsville is paying over
20% of the town's taxes including the
havil fire department and the havil road
department with no return to
Woodsville I agree with Rick that
probably this should uh a final decision
on this should probably be postponed
until after the uh Supreme Court cases
are
decided but you still need to come up
with a a middleof the road
formula to get the funding back in place
since since this has taken place there's
been absolutely no initiative on the hav
of selectman to sit down with the
Woodsville Commissioners and work it out
and right's right and Wrongs wrong and
fair is fair thank you thank
you
questions I see none thank you very much
for your testimony
um from the
Dr can we have just one of you come up
or is it imperative you have both
here I'm assuming you're going to say
so okay I guess we believe we need both
uh and Roth
team good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm Peter Ro I'm a I'm an
attorney with the Department of Revenue
ad BR bring mic closer to your mouth so
we can hear you my name is Peter Ro I'm
an attorney with the Department of
Revenue Administration I've been
involved in the matters between
Woodsville and haal since approximately
2019 including the um issues that are
now in front front of the Supreme Court
and um
the this bill that's in front of the
legislature now and how it its Origins
and I can answer any questions about
that if you wish um with respect to the
Supreme Court to well first I should
introduce uh my name is Adam donon core
I'm the assistant director of the
municipal and property division at the
so the the the case was argued to the
Supreme Court at the beginning of
January and we're expecting a decision
really at any point I check the docket
literally every day to see what the
decision is um
the case was argued to the Supreme Court
really sort of in two different ways the
Woodsville argued the case as sort of a
larger question about whether the
warrant IAL approach that was in the
2021 legislation ought to be followed
which was the basis for its appeal to
the Department of Revenue Administration
over hail's tax rate and I know that's
kind of confusing the department through
the Department of Justice argued to the
court that the case should be decided on
a very narrow basis of jurisdiction and
that is the uh the timing for
woodville's appeal was not correct and
Woodsville did not have standing to to
appeal the tax rate that was assigned to
the uh to the town of hail Woodsville
could have appealed its own tax rate but
it didn't and instead it appealed hail's
tax rate so it's our expectation and
belief that the Supreme Court will and
should anyway decide the matter on a
narrower jurisdictional basis that
doesn't really help move the pieces any
further on the board to get us to you
know sort of a resolution of what's
going on here but one of the things that
we discovered in looking at the the
legislation and I I studied the
legislation back to 1880 something and
and the most current version which was
put forth by Senator GAA in 2021 but
also previously in
2020 was to create this sort of I think
everybody believed anyway that two
things were going to happen one the
parties that is hail and Woodsville
would talk that didn't Happ happen but
it was also the belief that the IDE I
think the idea was to separate the the
sort of interwined of the two
entities there was left in the in the
legislation in 2021 the ability for the
voters at town meeting to put forth
warrant articles and so there's a
dispute about what that meant and um
Senator GAA believed and there's there's
there's a letter to to that effect that
this was a very narrow way for uh hail
to fund certain programs that Woodsville
was carrying on on hail's behalf and I
believe the ambulance service was one of
them maybe the library I'm not sure
exactly what they were but what it what
happened instead is at the town meeting
in
2022 the uh Woodsville people
essentially showed up and for the
meeting and the weather was poor and
there was covid concerns at that time
and so they put through warrant articles
funding both the fire department and the
road department in
full and there's some dispute about what
those numbers should have been but
that's what sort of sort of started this
most recent version of the problem the
the current bill that was started off by
Senator gray to resolve the ambiguity
that was believed in the statute about
what those L those words were intended
to accomplish
was it a narrower view as Senator GAA
felt or was it just open-ended because
right now the way it's written it's kind
of an open-ended invitation for people
to come to the town meeting and vote for
Appropriations for
Woodsville the issue that come that this
sort of sits on top of I think is that
Village districts and fire districts are
intended to be essentially
self-supporting through either fees that
they charge their residents for what the
services that they provide or through
their own forms of Taxation and so the
idea that this the taxpayers of haal
would be essentially subsidizing the
programs that this The Village District
in uh Woodsville is sort of contrary to
that General principle and to answer the
the representative's question what is uh
Woodsville
um Woodsville was formed as a fire
district under like an 18 50 law and
then it had additional amendments that
were added to it to give it additional
powers and to make it a little more
complicated they do
things that they've developed over the
years that are not really fully
explained by the the session laws that
were enacted to form it and Empower it
and so I think Senator Gray's idea in
this bill was to essentially make
Woodsville like every other Village
District but the when he started with
that what he learned from the parties
and from Woodsville and from hail was
that there is still this
interconnectedness in terms of funding
and the idea that he came up with this
formula as I observed it was to make it
so that the fact that Woodsville people
are paying taxes to the town of Hao for
services that Woodsville is essentially
providing itself that is fire and Roads
that there should be some kind of an
offset so that Woods people aren't
paying essentially double and so his
formula here was attended to accomplish
a sort of a rough justice of that and I
I guess that's all I I have to say about
it I'm happy to take any questions and I
don't know if Adam has anything in
addition
question representative Guthrie thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question uh could you tell me there each
entity that is involved in this I still
understand I think there's either
there's either five or six do they all
have a separate tax
rate yeah so each each Village District
in Hil gets their they pay taxes to hail
and they also have a village District
tax rate wow so if they're appropriating
on their own for their own purposes
they'll pay a tax rate based on those
Appropriations but they also pay as
they're also residents of the town of
April follow up Mr chairman if I could
yeah go ahead thank you uh does that
that mean they each have their own
budget that's correct they have their
own governing body they have their own
budget legislative body they're little
little tiny versions of towns that are
established for a specific purpose or
set of
purposes thank you thank you Mr
chairman representative priest thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
questions what I'm hearing is that H the
Senate Bill 448 would just make the
situation even more complex and
problematic and it would not resolve the
issues that are confronting the villages
and the town of haill is that
correct I think the purpose of the of
the bill in its current form was to
replace
the um funding by Warren article that
can be
dependent on a lot of different factors
and is a little bit um uh strange with a
more set and standard Financial
agreement that could also be uh
supplanted by an actual agreement
between the two parties so I think the
idea here was to establish uh Woodsville
as a village District just as every
other Village District in the state is
and replace their kind of unorthodox
system uh with something that's more
standardized as a followup Mr chairman
thank you again um with this
legislation and the pending Supreme
Court
decision depending upon which way it
goes we would be seeing you again at
another
legislation uh year to on another bill
problem I don't know the answer to that
sorry representative power thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so we know and we understand
according to statute that Village
districts are established for a specific
purpose and that they have the power and
the authority to tax to fund those
purposes so my question is are there any
other examples of Village districts that
are established
in which the funding is
not from within that Village districts
either all or part maybe not all is
probably
inappropriate are there other Village
districts where part of the funding for
the purpose of which that Village
District was established comes
from the town in which the the greater
town in which the village district is
part of I can say terms of a warrant
article directly to fund a a village
District purpose that's not something
that we see in any other
place but the there may be instances
where there are specific sort of
contractual relationships between them
over specific programs or uh things that
lales thank thank you for the edif
edification of my colleagues I'd just
like to say that Woodsville is well
known throughout the state for their
softball team they have won the state
championship two of the last three years
for their division and they are
currently undefeated so I would hope
that whatever happens with this
legislation that that that doesn't
change that Woodsville will always be
proud of their softball
you uh okay uh are there any more
questions regarding the legislation
representative power thank you Mr
chairman I had a followup to my previous
questions thank you for taking my
followup so following up to my what I
had asked before I was
what I would like to ask is with regards
to Village districts are there any
statutes which prescribe a formula for
funding similar to what was previously
in statute which was repealed and now
that we see here and with this bill
seen yes represent sen of Tetro go
ahead you're hard to see down there I'm
sorry
never um thank you Mr chairman and
thanks for taking our questions
I'm having a hard time
wondering
why it it seems though each Town's
trying to do their own thing and can't
get together on how you fund it but
there's plenty of examples throughout
the state for the mutual Aid systems why
why can't you work it out that way um I
mean we've gone so far as not only fire
we've got um Public Works Mutual Aid
systems you know Police Department
Mutual Aid System why can't you follow
thank you for the question um that's not
something that the Department of Revenue
has any control over um the relationship
between Woodsville and holl is kind of
their business and I think that that you
know from my perspective that's an
excellent point to be made to them but
that's not something that the Dr has any
uh particular um power over or uh means
of putting in place
Place representative stavis thank you Mr
chair very very quickly because I think
I may have missed this at when you first
sat down are you in support of or
against this
bill we we don't take a position on the
bill itself I'm sorry we're but we're
we've been working we worked with
Senator gray during the the formula to
provide information and insight about uh
the economics and and the law and that's
what we've been trying to do here
today follow up yet Dr does not
typically come up with spending formulas
or taxing formulas for Village districts
is that correct that's
correct further
questions I see none thank you gentlemen
for your testimony last but not least
good morning it's still morning my name
is Lindsay NATO I am an attorney at Orin
Reno just down the street um and we
represent the Woodsville fire district
in various legal matters and that's how
we became aware of this piece of
legislation um I want to reiterate that
Woodsville similar to many of you would
like to never have to be back here ever
again that's I think Universal um we are
here once again because the town of hail
keeps bringing legislation to try to
change the playing field and so I think
we appreciate the work that the Senate
did trying to introduce amendments to
Senate Bill 448 that would make the
playing field a bit more equal but we
don't feel like it actually achieved
that and so I think as Kevin um Shelton
the T the district administrator stated
earlier we do have two changes that we
would suggest to add back in capital
projects and to make the um fire
calculation of per capita bis um to help
even the playing field so that both
parties do have incentive in a perfect
world if they can come together and come
to agreement I think that's the only way
to really get them there so if you are
interested in moving forward with
legislation we would suggest making
those two
changes I'm going to answer a couple
quick questions um knowing that I stand
between you and your executive session
and lunch um so representative power you
had asked essentially what is Woodsville
it's established in session laws so it's
currently not in the rsas and so part of
what Senator gray tried to do was put it
into the rsas so that it was um easier
to follow basically um so that's how it
is it does have under you'll see um
chapter 52 Village districts there are a
bunch of different purposes for which V
Village districts can be created it
originally was created for extinguishing
fires it has over the years been
expanded um and it basically includes
most except for two um of the purposes
that are established in RSA 521 so it is
pretty broad which is why we get into
these issues about it looking like its
own town even though it is part of the
overall haval
Community I think one thing that gets
lost is that Woodsville fire district
residents are also hail residents right
so when we're talking about votes
happening and having warrant articles be
voted on that's everyone in hail who's
who's voting
on those issues when they come up um so
I'm just going to touch on just a few
brief points I had a lot more to say but
I think most of it has already been
covered so since Inception in 1885
Woodsville has operated its fire
department and then since at least the
early 1900s Woodsville has always
received its proportionate share back of
town tax revenues for woodville's
Highway operations so again taxpayers
pay in they're asking for that back so
that they're not getting double taxed um
um and so I think that's a key Point
here up until 2019 the parties worked
well together there were different
formulas and systems in place informally
and then formally um in law where the
town and District were able to work out
agreements on the funding structures in
2019 we saw holl under some new
management decided to reinterpret this
historical Arrangement that was used and
demanded back funds from the district
this led to years of litigation um over
basically the legislation in place in
2009 through 2019 in which Woodsville
ultimately prevailed and the court cited
with Woodsville on a summary judgment
motion the parties then settled the
remainder of that
lawsuit while the 2019 litigation was
pending hail then petitioned the
legislature to change the law so that it
would be basically up to the hail voters
to decide how much to appropriate to
Woodsville and that's where we currently
are um the law currently states that any
Appropriations to the Woodsville fire
district dist shall be as directed by
Warren articles duy voted by the voters
present and voting at each annual holl
town meeting so that is what has been
happening um for the last few years in
2022 haal Town voters approved warrant
articles voting to appropriate funds to
woodville's high fire and Highway
departments um those amounts didn't
cover the full amount of either
department but you know better than
nothing uh the Dr took issue with the
warrant articles um approved by the
voters and so that's really the issue
those warant articles are the issue of
the current New Hampshire Supreme Court
appeal um and you know I think there is
some sense in waiting for that decision
to come out um to see how the court
sides and interprets current law before
you go change existing law um now again
we're back here again and just as the
court was expected to settle the issues
around that hey roll came back again and
I was trying to you know I think in
woodville's view s away funding from
Woodsville um and try to gain control
and so that's really where we're at um
the initial version of the bill as
introduced removed the language allowing
the voters to appropriate funds to
Woodsville um thankfully Senator gray
and Perkins quoka really worked well
together and tried to resolve the
dispute by creating basically a default
formula as you've heard um while we
appreciate that sentiment um and
hopefully the parties can come to
agreement at some point it doesn't look
like close to that and so we do think
that any default formula that gets
passed needs to be more balanced to give
both sides incentive to come to the
table fairly and reach um an an
agreement in good faith so um I do have
uh Amendment language if you're
interested in it just adding back in the
capital projects which is essentially
the same formula that was used for the
highway formula from 2009 to 2019 so
that would revert back to that and then
making the fire per capita um since the
density in the district is much greater
Woodsville population density as the
economic Center is over 700 per square
mile while while just ha rolls is about
91 people per square mile so you can see
if you're looking at fire calls who's
going to get more calls the more densely
populated areas um so again I just want
to say that we appreciate all the work
that's been done we appreciate this uh
you taking the time this morning and I'm
questions question
questions you're gonna let me off I
guess you had awesome testimony you have
no questions okay that was the last pin
card I have on uh SB 448 was there
anybody else looking to speak seeing
none we will close the hearing on S SP
448 okay we are only about 50 minutes
behind so what we will do is take our
lunch now we we will begin our exec
session after lunch uh why don't we have
everybody back here right at one be
e
okay folks we're going to get going here
we're going to open up the executive
session we got a a bunch of bills 1 2 3
4 5 six seven or eight of them we're
going to start with the Senate Bill 63
relative to the adoption of Public
Health ordinances by
municipalities and with that I
understand representative Cahill has a
amendment to propose yes I propose uh to
pass um um this amendment of
15518 on thank you and do we have a
seconds and would you like to speak to
your Amendment yeah I'll speak briefly
to my Amendment you know um I I I see
this amendment as a simple simplifying
things and taking out some language and
nuisances okay thank you does anybody
want to
speak to the
amendment representative priest thank
you Mr chairman I think this is very
shortsighted um because I think Health
Care officers do much more than just be
proa Ian not proactive but reactive to
anything that comes up they need to be
proactive and they are proactive if you
step out and let them do what they're
supposed to be doing and I think this
bill and this amendment does not do that
and so therefore I will be opposing this
amendment and the Bill thank you thank
comments seeing none when the clerk
clerk is ready could we call the role on
H Vice chairman power
no clerk votes yes representative as
Silas yes representative
Kella
yes representative
award yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill oh
yes Representative stavis no
representative Tetro
no Representative
majori no representative
Gallagher
no representative Hicks no
representative Howland
no representative Priest
No representative Frack
no Mr chairman uh yes and uh we
have a sub for representative Kelly I
forgot to mention representative Wallace
is sitting in I'm sorry so uh just need
to call his also uh representative
Wallace
to9 okay so if it's 9 to9 it does not uh
pass uh is there another amendment I
has yes Mr chair I would like to move
05h thank you and do we have a second on
that I'll second that representative
Elward seconds that would you like to
yella um this amendment adds
language um that specify uh similar
threats to Public Health such as
groundwater water contamination septic
breaches hazardous waste releases or
other public health threats resulting
from flooding as was uh uh given to you
at the at the Committee hearing so
please support it thank you other
comments
on 1550 representative
Holland um so when we heard uh in the at
the public hearing when we heard
testimony uh the thing that really came
up there was masking came up and
immunization came up uh were were how
municipalities had enacted it and and it
seems to be the the uh impetus for this
legislation that we don't allow uh
municipalities to to regulate that and
and so of course we're looking at now
nuisances the thing is is that and
unfortunately I served on both the
school board and the Town Council during
covid uh covid a a highly infectious
airborne disease that kills a million
people really wasn't in our Playbook and
as a
municipality it really overwhelmed our
ability to regulate we didn't know
anything about it and so it really was
the duty of the state to regulate the
public health element of it and
initially they they did do that they
closed the schools down and we tried to
figure out how to actually make it work
but as we moved in the summer and then
to the fall and we're being asked to to
reopen the schools the state failed us
they did not provide us with clear uh
regulation they they said well these are
some ideas we have but we'll leave it up
to the local municipality to figure out
how to make it work and so they punted
their responsibility to us and the state
at any time can override any local uh
regulation particularly when it deals
with an emergency but they chose not to
and it was excruciating as we made our
way through the school year the state
finally after we had come up with
matrixes to like when it was actually
safe to open and when we could have
Staffing the state overruled all of that
and uh said we could not mask and that
we had to go back in person they could
have done that at any time initially and
helped us work through the prop work
through the uh the pandemic but they
chose not to and so now when I look at
this as we've moved away from covid uh
rather than saying we want the state to
take responsibility for uh for uh
medical emergencies were saying what the
local mun penalizing local mun
municipality who had to deal with the
failure of the state by saying that we
can't regulate it and so to say that I
have trust issues about the state is an
understatement I think this legislation
is not necessary uh solving health
crisises is a partnership between the
municipality and the state this does not
help
that other comments representative yella
thank you um I actually
with all due respect I completely
disagree with representative Howen that
this bill has anything to do with Co um
and there's an entire
investigation um done by the house right
now investigating the covid response and
this is not a byproduct of that
investigation um in fact um I am aware
of the
testimony of that was brought forward
and um the prime sponsor said that their
main um kind of impetus and thing that
got them enthusiastic about this was the
blatant overreach by some municipalities
by regulating tattooed parlors and
saying that they needed to have medical
doctors as tattoo artists and that um
and there are other examples like um
municipality in in uh Kingston puts has
a uh has a ordinance done by their
health officers regulating the uh
migration of birds and what you can't if
you can feed them or not those are
absolute examples that that of of
overreach that this bill is specifically
trying to address things that the that
the state the state regulates tattoo
artists not the municipality they are
blatantly overreach and so I think that
this addresses that most of all
it uh it would kept on being asked if if
uh the covid was a nuisance no it's a
public health emergency a nuisance is
not a public health emergency Public
Health Emergency does let let raise to
the level of a state level thing that
needed to be addressed and all of that
stuff but but this is far more reaching
um than just that topic and so that is I
think that what we should be you know
when you're thinking of a of a
bad policy put forward by um the the
uh Public Health officers think of the
regulation of tattoo artists and the
regulation of what you can and cannot do
to to um you know wild geese that are in
flying around and Landing next to your
child uh representative
stavis thank you Mr
chair um with all due respect to tattoo
poers and migrating
geese um I have been on the municip and
County government committee for going on
six years now and ever since Co
we have had this bill come before us
every single time um believe once it
passed a few times it didn't pass but
it's kind of like the undead it keeps
coming
back I um believe that Statewide Health
emergencies frequently emerge at the
local level first and I don't just
believe this I know this from experience
because when I was at Dartmouth I was
co-chair of the uh Emergency Management
committee there uh we had an outbreak of
hemorrhagic influenza in the
undergraduate student population that
was identified by our town Public Health
officer at the time and because that
public health officer was able to do his
job and inform the community and inform
the administration of Dartmouth only one
student died what we had a situation
where dozens and dozens of students
could have died and could have spread to
other towns and Statewide so I will not
be supporting this amendment and I will
not be supporting this Bill thank
you uh representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman
um I guess my whole issue during the
testimony was a simple statement that
they made U the state people regarding
that the fact that uh Public Health
officers only have to have 3 hours of
training to be able to hold that job in
a municipality and I don't think that's
adequate for them to be able to handle
some of the things that that come up in
in in the townships right now so I I
think that uh something that limits
their Authority uh is appropriate and i
would support this amendment I'm not
saying that it's perfect but I think we
need to do something different to get
this under control a little bit thank
you represent PRI thank you Mr chairman
I will not be supporting
Amendment 1
155h for the same purposes that I have
stated previously I think it's way too
restrictive it does not include
emergency preparedness or infectious
disease prevention or chronic disease
prevention or
immunization we right now we have
outbreaks of polio happening in our
communities in which the health officers
are the first ones to look at this and
to get help for their communities
they're there to look for the Health and
Welfare and safety of their people and
this amendment restricts them to a very
minimal task and does not address this
issue thank
you further comments representative
kahill thank you Mr chair you
know prior to being on this committee I
worked in a human research lab for the
US Army um and we did human research
humans so I probably forgot a little a
lot more than um most of you guys are
ever going to know about this sort of
thing and I do have a question from my
colleague over there um how many actual
times have you called your health
officer and asked him to do something
like that like several times because
they're responsible for making sure that
the restaurants don't pass out cont
food that's how many times I mean how
many
times when a question is asked the uh
recipient first has
to make sure everything goes through the
chair and if the individual wishes to
answer then he can answer and if you
have another question you may ask the
question through the
chair uh I don't need any more
lales
no
representative maor go ahead thank you
Mr chairman I I I wanted to uh I wanted
to uh to pick up on something that I've
heard here and reflect back on something
that I've heard in my own Community the
minute we have to start writing things
down as far as the limits to what we can
and cannot do we've lost the battle
because we cannot include everything
that we can and cannot do um and so I
cannot support the amendment because as
we have heard and and I believe although
I do respect that a public health
officer needs more
training if we start listing what they
can and cannot do and put them into a
box I think we have put our own health
at risk I think we put ourselves at risk
so um I I think we should be looking at
this in a different way but I don't
comments representative PRI I would like
to convey my
um regret for having attacked my fellow
representative um and I forgot to go do
the proper protocol so I just want to
make sure that that is on the record
thank you represent PRI
oops further
comments seeing any
none we will ask the clerk to call the
155h okay excuse me Vice chairman power
yes representative Guthrie no clerk
votes yes representative vilus
yes representative Kella yes
representative Wallace yes
representative Howard yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
Representative stavis
no representative Tetro no
Representative majori no representative
Gallagher no representative Hicks no
representative Holland no representative
Priest No representative Frank no and Mr
chairman
yes uh motion fails 9 to9 thank you Mr
clerk okay that brings us back to
the original Bill sp63 do we have a
motion on that representative yok Kella
yeah I just move a to
pass is there a second on
that second representative kahill
seconds that would you like to speak to
the underlying bill um I think it's a
good bill and I look forward to offering
floor okay uh further
comments seeing none when the clerk is
ready we can call the rooll on the
underlying bill Senate Bill
63 as amended by the
Senate okay uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
yes clerk votes yes representative sales
yes representative Keller yes
representative Wallace yes
representative awood yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
no represent Tetro
no represent majori no representative
Gallagher no representative Hicks no
representative howling no no represent
priest no uh representative Frank no Mr
chairman
yes uh motion passes 10
to8 okay uh based on the 10 to8 I assume
this will well this will not go on the
consent calendar so um we have rep who's
going to write the committee report for
the majority is that going to be
representative kahill or yo Kell
representative kahill will write the
Report they all speak up at once
representative stavis will do the
Minority Report okay that closes the de
63 go
ahead go ahead turn your
mic if an amendment fails in an
executive session can it be offered as a
floor
amendment I do not know the answer to
okay the next uh Bill uh we're going to
exec is Senate Bill 531 relative to
background checks of Municipal Health
officers we'll open up the exec session
on that and I believe representative
power you have a motion thank you Mr
chairman I move ought to pass on Senate
Bill 531 thank you in uh second
Mr chairman go ahead I'll second that
representative lales seconds uh the
motion would you like to speak to your
motion representative power thank you Mr
chairman this bill um comes to us from
the Senate it was at the request of the
Department of Health and Human Services
and what it does is it um eliminates the
requirement for a background check on
nominees for the position of Health
officer to be sent to the commissioner
or his or her design at the Department
of Health and her Human
Services and the based on the the
hearing and testimony there were a
couple reasons why this was requested
one is that is that the health officer
is an employee of the town in which they
um serve therefore the it was the I
guess best practice is that the hiring
process including the obtaining of the
background check is in in addition to
the reviewing of that and that whole
hiring um process and procedure remain
at the local level and that uh
the that background check um did not
need to be submitted to
DHHS because once that whole hiring
was finalized that the nominee would be
the the name of the candidate would be
um submitted to
DHHS and they would appoint that
person and furthermore by keeping the
background check local it also addressed
any privacy concerns with the submission
and archival of of that um sensitive
information by DHHS so this this bill
makes sense and it streamlines things
thank
you so further comments on this bill
representative
Gallagher um so I initially was a bit
suspicious of this bill um just um based
on the idea of it but having found out
or um that uh DHHS is on board with it
that um
that uh mitigated my concerns so I'll be
supporting it too further
comments seeing none we'll ask the clerk
to call a rooll on Senate Bill
531 uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie yes cler votes
yes representative silus yes represent
Kella uh no representative Wallace yes
representative award
yes representative Brown yes
representative
kahill yes representative stavis
yes representative
Tetro
yes representative majori yes
representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland y representative
priest yes represent Frack yes Mr chair
chman
yes uh passes uh 17 to1 okay that passes
17 to1 this will go on the consent
unless there's an objection I don't see
an objection from representative yella
so we will go on to the consent uh
report representative
power okay with that we close the exact
y okay next up we have Senate Bill 447
uh establishing a committee to study the
inclusion of Transportation expenses in
default budgets we'll open up the exec
session on that and I believe
representative Cahill has a
motion yes I'd like to move Amendment
1500h for Senate Bill 447 thank you do
have a second second that please
representative Elward seconds that and
uh representative kahill would you like
to
speak yes uh this is a straightforward
Amendment it's um moving um on line five
you'll see that it changes
uh from one Senate member to this
committee thank you is there any
questions or
comments uh uh repres go thank you Mr
chairman I don't have a question but I
have a comment to respect to the uh in
inerting the U Amendment are we ever
going to get three from the other side
to attend the
meeting that's a very good question that
I cannot answer for
you thank you Mr
chair further
comments seeing none Mr clerk could you
call a
15008 okay Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie yes collect votes
yes representes yes represent
Kella
no representative Wallace yes
representative award yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
representative stavis yes yes
representative Tetro
yes representative majori yes
representative
Gallagher
no representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
Frack yes and Mr chairman
yes motion passes 16
to2 thank you and do we have a motion on
the uh Senate Bill 447 as amended by
1500h representative stavis I move ought
to pass on Senate Bill 447 FN thank you
and we have a second representative
priest is raising his hand he seconds uh
discussion seeing none when the clerk is
that okay Vice shamman
power yes representative guthe yes
collect votes yes representative lales
yes represent Kella no
representative Wallace yes
representative awood yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
representative stavis yes representative
Tetro yes representative majori yes
representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes represent
Frank yes and Mr chairman
yes motion pass is 17 to
one okay thank you Mr clerk uh again
this will go on consent unless there
is which I'm seeing a head shaking no so
this will go on the consent calendar and
that closes the exact session on Senate
Bill
447 report
auth oh yes uh report author is very
good thank you I show uh representative
stavis will you do the report on this
since
whenever yeah I'll speak to uh when the
okay next up Senate Bill
532 with a very very
long title that I'm not going to
read
um Senate Bill
532 representative Cahill I believe you
have an amendment to
introduce yes I move Amendment
20241 15698 on Senate Bill 5 32 thank
you do we have a second on that
representative Elward seconds that and
would you like to speak to it sir thank
you Mr
chair um this is a simple Amendment
that's adding a new section and in the
gist of the amendment is that it's
requiring the data to be on the website
for at least 90
comments represent stavis
question a technical requirement that
the amendment I believe
imposes um in the absence of a website a
political subdivision shall post the
information in two appropriate places do
those postings H have to remain in place
for 90 days and if those public places
are newspapers of General circulation
that's going to cost those
municipalities a ton of
money that is a valid point um I is a
valid point I I'll speak to that the
amendment as you aware representative
stavis was mine um I really didn't look
at the
posting in the two appropriate places
probably should have had it also um I
think they we were told there are only
five cities or whatever in the state
that does not have
websites or what's that more than that
five oh okay five um so actually you're
right oversight on my part
I that could be taken care of in a floor
Amendment if it's that uh important I
think representative
Elward um just just to respond to this I
I've always understood the word posting
to mean either to a website or to a
bulletin board and that publishing in a
publishing further comments represent
power thank you Mr CH thank you Mr
chairman with regards to this amendment
the last sentence it says in the absence
of a website a political subdivision
shall post the information in two
appropriate places seeing that um the 90
days is very specific to the posting on
a website I would say that
with regards to posting in two
appropriate places the the bill would be
silent so it it would be open-ended and
as you had suggested a floor Amendment
if this one somebody wanted to address
appropriate representative
Ella I'm going to be opposing this
amendment and the bill um which I will
will talk to more about when the bill
um in in
the in my vision which I'll expand upon
later that the uh posting would be
perpetual and um on the on the website
and so for that reason I'm going to
oppose this um and I will discuss
further about when the when we talk
about the bill
okay further
comments I see none when the clerk is
ready call the role on Amendment 224
H Vice chairman power yes representative
guthy yes CL votes yes representative
lales yes representative Ella No
representative Wallace yes
representative award yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
Representative stavis
no representative Tetro no
Representative
majori
no no representative Gallagher
uh
no representative Hicks I'll say yes
okay okay uh representative
howand I'm I'm gonna say no okay
representative
priest
yes representative Frank a hard no okay
and Mr chairman yes uh motion passes 11
to7
thank you Mr clerk okay um now we are on
to Senate Bill 532 as amended by 1569 H
do we have a motion on
that representative PRI I make a motion
to approve Senate Bill
532 as
amended thank you do we have a second on
that
representative lales seconds that
motion um do you have anything you would
like to say on that bill representative
PRI I believe in transparency you turned
your mic off I believe in transparency
and I believe that this
bill uh provides the the residents of of
all of our communities what we are doing
to them and by bringing back grants and
funding to to assist them and I think
this is very important to let them know
that government is working thank
you representative
yella thank you uh Mr chair and uh
hopefully um even though I think a lot
of people are uh right
now um expecting to vote in favor of
this that I will be able to convince
them otherwise
um I did some research on this directly
after the committee hearing I went over
because as I think I indicated in the
hearing that um there might that the
state might already know about all of
this information and um in fact of
course it does um the I went over to the
Department of Revenue and tried to see
if they might um have that information
and may actually already be posting it
and stuff like that and they pointed me
to um um the the governor's office which
has um up on its on one of its Myriad of
websites or um transparent New
Hampshire
uh website which has all of the um
vendor payments from the state already
on
it and there is a method for you to
search vendors and I plugged in my town
of
and I pulled up uh you know a recent
payment for school lunches to uh from
the state to uh to my town and so it's a
little bit clunky as far right now
because you're just searching by vendor
and that's all vendors not just
municipalities and stuff like that and
so I reached out to the um the
uh New Hampshire Department it
Department
that actually houses that website and I
spoke to the director earlier today and
they he indicated that um they obviously
transparent New Hampshire is a very uh
the website is is for transparency and
um is um has a bunch of this
information um and it's the information
is entered by the Legislative legisl of
administration um and he with without
the um he had not heard about this bill
like it had not gone through the course
of trying to get this information
through that website um but he is not
sure about whether there's a spot on on
their um inside of their accounting
software so that uh that you know the uh
vendor of the municipality could be
marked as as a a a municipality and then
because my vision was essentially just
have all municipalities kind of like a
link to just a place where there's
municipalities and you can look pick any
municipality and it would just list all
of the things and then then the
municipality could just put a link to
their website like it would be new
hampsh NH transparency. goov Freemont or
whatever and it would just be a
permanent link that you could just go
and see whatever um money you got from
from the state and it would essentially
require no upkeep by the municipality
but this has
just apparently been not really thought
of and actually the director um kind of
indicated that he preferred it be
handled by the state since we have all
the information and municipalities are
not very reliable it's not going to be
put up the way that we wanted and stuff
like that and so it I think that this
committee should hold off on this and
and I will work with the Department of
legislative Administration and the
depart the department of uh it uh doit
and we will you know work on it trying
to get that implemented and if there is
Need for legislative solution that we
can offer that in the next term um but I
don't think that this is absolutely
critical that we do it now and that we
impose that burden on the municipalities
it's possible that we could just s do
this at the state level and have
essentially very little to no burden on
the municipality so I would just offer
that for your consideration uh thank you
Mr
chair thank you representative Hicks
thank you Mr chairman um I agree that we
need transparency and I think that
posting a link is a great way to do it
um and I think that if posting a link
would satisfy this then I think it's a
wonderful idea um so I'm going to vote
for the bill um as amended and hope that
that link will satisfy the requirement
for
Lala thank you Mr chairman for all the
reasons cited
by representative yella I will be voting
bill representative Howland
thank you for taking my uh my statement
um so I I do support even though I was
nervous about the the 60 days posting
the
newspaper we actually do most of this
already on our website um I mean the
goal of of the budget process is to pass
the budget and so the more information a
budget is more than just numbers it's a
story and so providing this information
to the community really helps you
formulate the story as you go into to
the budget process and and you really
want the community it also builds trust
with the community when they can see
everything that's going on and I think
the added benefit really is is you
really do want to show what the state is
giving you because it lets the
municipality know how little it is and
it it shows how they've shifted the
burden to municipalities to carry this
out specifically as they downloaded the
retirement uh funding to us and so by
stating that it helps us as voters when
we think about our legislature so I I'll
support it representative kill thank you
Mr chair um you know I got this bag of
M&M's right here and it's got different
color M&M's red green yellow we all
retain and get information in different
ways and I totally respect
representative y's points on this I'll
be voting for this bill and for the like
we voted for the amendment and and
hopefully we can fix on the floor um the
one small issue
but I think it it better serves us if
we're presenting information in multiple
different ways I think it's great that
we have the state archive or whatever
but it will be very good for for the
employees of the town and the citizens
of the town to have this information
suggested had representative Gallagher
n um so I um I I don't really
necessarily um oppose the idea behind
this bill um yeah I I genely support um
transparency I
was actually considering draft getting
my own Amendment drafted to it though
which unfortunately I I'd wanted to meet
with someone from um the education
committee about it but just didn't get
around to it in time um yeah some things
that I would have wanted to change um
that if if I I on this amendment would
be to increase the um 30 days to say um
within 30 days of receipt to say within
60 or 90 days of receipt um and I also
would have liked to add some language um
about making sure that this applies
evenly to um public schools and other
sorts of Education types that the school
provide that the state provides funding
for um and then also my usual Tech
related stuff um about software freedom
and
um yeah stuff like that um but then
again these are all pretty minor
nitpicks um I don't think it really
leads to Too Much harm if the bill
doesn't include those Clauses currently
um so
yeah I'm I I I think I'll um I think
I'll support it anyways even though um
it's not
perfect representative
savus yes well I'm a firm believer in
never letting the perfect get in the way
of the good um and I see nothing in this
bill that precludes municipalities from
publishing information about other kinds
of educational institutions other than
public schools so that's one thing
another thing is I have also checked out
in research transparent New Hampshire
and I find it
impenetrable um uh if I wanted to find
out what kind of state funds had gone to
a certain municipality I don't even know
where I'd begin and the other thing is
that in Lebanon we do this every day we
have a daily update of opportunities and
Grant funds that have come in and what
and following up on what representative
Howland said it does give you the
opportunity as a municipality to
prioritize what you want to prioritize
and not to just link to someone else's
page that has their own priorities as to
what they list first or second or third
uh and it also gives you an opportunity
to tell about local people who might
have benefited from you know people you
may know your neighbors who may have
benefited from these funds so um I will
be supporting this bill I think it's a
step in the right direction I think we
can easily fix the 90day thing on the
floor if it even needs to be fixed uh it
just stuck out to me at the moment but
I'm not so sure it's that serious thank
you representative Hicks you had another
comment yes thank you I apologize for
not um thinking about this earlier I
think it must be on local municipalities
websites people are not going to go most
people are not going to go to the state
to look for information about their
towns or cities further comments
representa
since I agree with my Democratic
counterparts I wanted to make sure they
knew that I agreed and say that the that
that I've Agreed 100% on this type of
thing the transparency and the fact that
your information for your town should be
on your website so people who don't
spend a lot of time researching and
looking at this for a town can see where
they stand right away and you can just
point them when they ask questions about
things like this you can just point them
to their town website and it's done
One-Stop shopping thank you very good
represent of
Elwood I guess I really have a question
because in my
town it seems to be such a burden to
post anything to the
website and I'm getting the impression
from our
new assistant
selectman's
assistant that um she's not trained in
how to post a PDF or whatever to the
website so what exactly would be
required of the
municipality to would they have to pay
someone to post this information if they
don't know how or what is the process
does anybody
know do anybody want to talk about that
representative kahill I I'll address a
little bit of that I mean currently
right now you have people administering
the website that posts when it's time to
vote or post when it's trash day or post
numerous other Public Notices I think it
would be very easy for them to be able
to do this um like Beyond easy I I would
like to also say I I completely agree
with representative stav some of those
websites are hard to navigate which is
why I brought out the M&M's we all see
information and learn information
differently and we need easy easy um
easier access and I'll agree with
representative Hicks and I'll agree with
disagree any further
comments shall we whip this horse
anymore
no okay
yes Mr clerk could you call a rooll
yes Senate Bill 532 as amended by
1569 Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie yes CL votes yes
representative sales yes Representative
ellaa no representative Wallace yes
representative awood yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
representative stavis yes representative
Tetro yes representative majori yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
franch yes and Mr shamman yes motion
one okay uh looks like we have
representative lalis down for the
committee report he's got a thumbs
thumbs up there it will go on the
consent calendar unless there's an
representative yella objects so it will
go on the regular calendar I'll write a
committee report or Minority Report okay
very
good and with that uh we'll close the
amended
okay what we'll do is we'll do one more
and then take take a quick uh maybe
10-minute Break
um next we have Senate Bill 491 relative
to authorizing legislative bodies of
municipalities to enter into voluntary
agreements with owners of private
roads representative Brown I understand
you might have a motion I do Mrs
chairman um basically um I object to
this uh Bill primarily because motion
can I make the motion sorry gosh so
jumpy
today make the motion to
it very good do we have a second uh
seconds now representative would you
like to speak to your bill uh your
motion I can't remember anymore
actually uh Mr chairman I think the
reason why I object to this is uh
numerous reasons I don't think the bill
was written very clearly I think that uh
the one person who testified to this
brought up issues with Dees and runoff
and those types of things which already
covered by regulations should be easily
addressed by the uh town of that's an
issue I think it sets up potential
questions in the future for uh what we
know uh we don't want to address and
that's the fact that people want
townships to take over their private
roads um so I think that's
enough okay further comments
representative Holland so full
disclosure I have a a three season cabin
down a private road and I couldn't quite
figure out especially in the testimony
where the person was coming up and he I
I assumed he was talking about runoff
and last year we did have some really
epic torrential rains that caused a lot
of runoff
but but most of the areas that to
mitigate it are all private property and
the road letting the town work on the
road wouldn't fix any of the runoff on
the private property and and the second
thing is I know everybody keeps saying
that we want the towns to take over our
private road but actually we we on our
private we don't want the state to take
over our private road we're perfectly
happy with the way it is we collect
money we maintain it and we really the
only people we want coming down our
private road the people who live on our
private
road representative uh Elward thank you
Mr chairman and full disclosure I reside
on a private road um a six lot
subdivision and it's very private and we
want to keep it that way um but the
language using
um authorizing the legislative body
um to enter into voluntary agreements
with owners of private roads I believe
is
incorrect it would be the governing body
that would actually contract with the
private with the owners of private roads
not the voters
Contracting
with I'm sorry there's just discussions
going on all over the place and I I'm
hearing voices and I can't think
straight when people are talking
continue so anyway I believe the
language is an error using the word
legislative
body representative PRI thank you Mr
chairman I will be supporting uh this
bill because um I'm I'm sorry I will be
opposing this bill because I think there
is unintended consequences that will AR
rise because of it this bill was created
for one particular property owner um who
owns property and maybe develops
property on a private road and he's
trying to get the the town to take over
the management and the um maintenance of
this road and I think it doesn't really
address all the issues that will be
arising from the enactment of this Bill
Kella thank you Mr chair um I'm going to
be opposing this bill mainly because
it's a um inserting new
language and there was a Supreme Court
decision
about um you know ownership and and uh
their decision was based on New
Hampshire law as it has to be and
so if you want to
clarify
whatever um statute that they relied on
to to say like hey there's a opportunity
for them to maintain it but not take
ownership of it or something like that
then it would need to amend the law that
the Supreme Court based its ruling on
and so because it's inserting new
legislation and um not really addressing
what the the law was based on I uh in
addition to the confusing language I'm I
think that they need to do more research
on the uh that Supreme Court law or
basis for the Supreme Court ruling and
amend the law that it was based on so
thank
you representative
Gallagher um so I also oppose this bill
but in kind of from the opposite
direction um from most of the previous
um people who have spoken um most people
so far have said something to the effect
of we don't want municipalities taking
over private roads um I do want
municipalities taking over private roads
but I think that when they do that they
shouldn't be private anymore this whole
thing of oh the municipality is going to
be on the hook for it but it's still
going to be private anyways um just
doesn't really cut it for me um
so yeah I that that is my separate
reason for opposing
it representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman uh like the rest of the people
who spoke full disclosure I live on a
private road with five other people as
well and I I want to uh Echo
representative priest comment in that
that we had one person who testified for
this and no towns spoke in favor of
doing this thank you representative uh
power thank you Mr chairman I'll just
briefly comment that it's my
understanding that this bill doesn't
allow for anything new to
be able to be done that can't already be
done in statute for example there's
already Provisions in law that the
governing body can enter into an
agreement um to do some of the stuff
that this um Bill potentially seeks to
furthermore a municipality is already
enabled to say plow a driveway where the
resident has called for an ambulance and
that's on a per case basis as needed in
the
emergency and um the last comment that
I'll make is I find that the wording of
the bill is is is is poor and it's
confusing and with regards to um the
first sentence legislative bodies
entering into
agreements um what that is referring to
is that that agreement would be approved
by a warrant article somewhat confusing
further
comments okay seeing no further comments
representative uh Mr clerk will call a
rooll on Senate Bill 491 please of the
motion of
itl Vice chairman power yes
representative
Guthrie yes clict votes yes
representative Lal
yes representative Kella
yes representative Wallace yes
representative award yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
representative
stavis yes representative Tetro
yes representative majori yes
representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest
yes represent Frank yes and Mr chairman
Z okay uh Senate Bill 491 representative
Brown will be running the committee
report it will go on consent unless
there are any dissension on that
represent Wallace you want to
no okay we'll go on consent that'll
close the exec session on Senate Bill
491 it is 5 after we will resume in uh
minute
e
going
gonna the tyrannical despot is looking
stavis that's what she called me that's
me okay goingon to open up the uh ex
session on cille 383 relative to local
tax caps representative power I
understand you have a motion yes um
thank you Mr chair I'd like to offer the
committee Amendment
1520 to Senate Bill 383 FN thank you do
we have a second on
that representative lales second set
would you like to speak to your
Amendment yes thank you Mr chairman um
the Senate was um informed that an
amendment was in order and it's a very
simple Amendment um to clarify a couple
of things
Unfortunately they um punted and said
that I could take care of it when the
bill came here to the house so
apparently I'm their secretary so
nevertheless there's um two simple
changes in line six in the original bill
as presented there was the word adopted
and that's changed to the word current
and the reason is is that the first year
um the adopted per pupil cost that that
that's what's adopted for the first year
but in years thereafter it's it's really
the current per pupil cost so that just
adds Clarity and then the in lines 9
through 12 there was just the addition
of a couple of sentences to further
clarify that um regards to the
calculation um that the current per
pupil cost is is compounded year after
year and so those um sentences there
just further clarify I I um would urge
the committee to um accept this
amendment for for clarity purposes thank
you thank you further comments on the
amendment I see none would the clerk
Vice chairman power yes representative
Guthrie yes collect votes yes
representative lales yes representative
Ella yes representative Wallace yes
representative award yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
Representative stavis
no representative Tetro
no Representative
majori no
representative
Gallagher no representative Hicks no
Representative howand no representative
Priest No representative Frack no and Mr
chairman yes motion passes 10 to8 thank
you do we now have a motion from uh
representative
power thank you Mr chairman I move ought
to pass as amended with Amendment
224-1 1520 to Senate Bill
383 and do we have a second on that
representative lalis has his hand up for
the second would you like to speak to
your bill sure thank you yep thank you
Mr chairman um this bill is enabling
legislation and it adds um a new
optional adjustment method to the um
statute pertaining to a local tax cap
and additionally it um provides for a
new optional School District budget cap
again both of these are enabling
legislation it's optional both towns and
school districts can opt to adopt either
of these as Tools in their toolbox for
um managing their their um Taxation and
their
expenditures um in either the the town
or the the school district
for the comments on the bill as amended
representa
soles thank you Mr chairman and I just
wanted to share with my colleagues uh as
a former selectman in the town of
Lichfield we have a uh uh a spending cap
and it had a restriction that it could
only go up a finite amount every every
uh year and we wished that we had the
option of tying it to some
inflationary uh index so it could it
could go up based upon that and so this
is a step in the right direction and it
it would have made things a lot better
budgeting representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman I will be
voting against this bill and the
amendment I appreciate the uh effort
that representative power has made on uh
trying to clarify um language in this
document but I'm just opposed with tax
cuts caps because of the fact that the
localities pay the cost pay the burden
if they have an economic downturn or if
something um unusual happens like we had
with the pandemic where there's a loss
of jobs and revenue and they are held
you know trying to provide services to
the uh to their people and their
businesses and I just think it
hampers um local governments so I and I
know that this enabling and I appreciate
that but I still am opposed to the
entire concept thank you thank you f the
comment
representa K I think this is a fantastic
uh bill being fiscally responsible for
our um for our constituents is
definitely the right thing to do with
all with the current economic situation
um a lot of people are concerned with
the um overspending of our government
and you look at our federal level it's
pretty insane uh if we if we only had a
tax cap on our federal spending it would
it would be amazing for us right now I
think um so I definitely will be voting
in favor of of the bill thank you
further comments representative uh maor
thank you Mr chairman um I'm going to be
voting against the bill I I really don't
have a problem with with the with the
calculator because I actually do support
the idea of tying a creating a calculus
and using uh CPI that's what we do when
we do our our contracts in town because
you need something to base it off of uh
and something that everyone can seek
their sink their teeth into where my
concern is is in the beginning in in
lines four and five uh and it's because
Northampton did that several years ago
we included the tax impact on all of our
warrant articles as we put them on there
and what happened is uh that we did not
we could not over the course of I think
it was three years represent the full
impact because if you pass seven but not
eight if you pass Six and not you know
and not nine what does that mean for us
and and I I it created a problem in
Northampton I think it might create
problems in other communities and for
that reason um I I I don't support that
piece so I'm not supporting the bill but
I do think the calculus is a good idea
thank
you further
comments representative power thank you
Mr chairman
um with regards to the comment that my
colleague just made on page one lines
four and five of the bill that language
is the same language that was um
contained in a bill and unfortunately I
was the Prime sponsor and I don't
remember the bill number Bill numbers
blur um for me at this point but knowing
that that bill passed um the
house I wanted to make sure because this
bill here addressed local tax caps I
wanted to make sure that that same
language was was also in this um bill
that's before us so this isn't anything
before see no more hands raised uh Mr
clerk when you are ready could we call a
rooll on Senate Bill 383 as amended by
1528 Vice chairman power yes
representative guby yes collect votes
yes representative lales yes represent
Ella yes representative Wallace yes
representative awood yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
Representative stavis
no representative Tetro no
representative Maori no representative
Gallagher no representative Hicks no
representative Howland no representative
Priest No representative Frack no and Mr
chairman
yes uh otpa passes 10 to8 thank you Mr
clerk uh
this will go on the regular calendar
representative power will be writing the
committee report for the majority and
by represented majority will be writing
Report that closes the exact session on
Senate Bill
383 before we hit the next one just a
comment I've had questions about
committee
reports um there's going to be three
bills that if you're the committee
writer on I need those by this evening
I'm in jury duty again all day tomorrow
and we have a deadline um that I need to
get these three in on and that is Senate
Bill
532 and especially 538 which we will
here next all right so if you're
committee report on either of those
evening the rest of them you can get get
them in to me at your leisure preferbly
morning and representative power could
you uh I know we haven't done 5:38 yet
but on uh 63 and 532 who are the
Senate Bill 63 the report author is
representative Cahill and Senate Bill
you okay with that we will move on to
5308 as amended by the Senate relative
to zoning procedures concerning
residential
housing and representative Brown I
believe you have a motion yes I do Mr
chairman I'd like to make a motion to it
bill itl Senate Bill 538 local thank you
second that's you
rich second second reprentative
lales and representative Brown would you
like to speak to your bill I wouldn't Mr
chair I I wouldn't Mr chairman there's
uh several things that concern me during
testimony of this bill and uh part of it
was the fact that uh the property tax
relief that could be granted uh even
though it says it's a
one-time uh period uh it could be
granted for a number of years and I
think they said up to 13 but I don't see
where it would be uh where they could
restrict it uh at all up to the 20e time
period the other issues that I that I
have with this are excuse me get to my
notes when I asked about the uh Park
parking issues um having U Been a civil
engineering project manager on numerous
proog projects around the world parking
is always a touchy issue and uh where
this is so open I have concerns about
that not being appropriate for the
locations and would like to think that
maybe the towns could address it but I
don't feel that it's clear here and the
other issue uh one of the primary ones
that I have is down at line 25 to 28 on
the third page which talks about the
planning boards and it says basically
once this is approved the planning
boards are required or shall be required
to approve the alternative parking
solution proposed by the ACT applicant
as a substitute for the proposed
residential use meeting on-site parking
requirements so if the township felt
there was a problem with parking they
it thank you further
comments representative holl so I I
actually like the Bild a couple of
things the the 79e component you it
there's a lot of flexibil first of all
you don't have to adopt it but if you do
adopt it you have the flexibility in
terms of the length of how you do it um
I think one of the concerns that people
have used 79e is just be careful how
long you give the 79e um the second the
thing I like about 79e also is it
doesn't require the municipality to come
up with an in any money upfront since
you're freezing the assessment there's
no upfront cost you lose some taxation
but you'll gain it the long run because
you let a project go through the part I
like I was on a Town Council form of
government and so in terms of zoning we
have a lot of flexibility we can bring
forth amendments regularly it works
works really really in terms of how that
works with the planning board um if a
zoning Amendment comes up it goes to the
planning board first the planning board
works on it and then it'll ultimately
come to the Town Council for approval
and as I say this just gives a you know
for us we take it for granted that it
could be October we decide you know this
zoning amendment is a really good one
let's bring this forward or it just
gives you a lot of flexibility so I
think that's a really the part of this
for the comments representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman um I too will
be uh voting against the itl and am
supporting uh HB 538 for many reasons
that my colleague has just noted I does
I do think that this gives the uh local
governments the some more tools to work
with in to providing affordable housing
within their jurisdictions and all of
the sections of this is it's up to them
to enact so we're not forcing them to um
to do this uh to use these tools we're
just giving them the
opportunity of using them if the
situation arises and they are in need of
affordable housing and I think this is a
win-win for everyone thank
you further comments representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman I guess the
other issue that I have with this is
that this work can be done uh currently
by developers without without this Bill
thank you representative
Gallagher um so I'm in support of this
bill and against the itl motion um I
actually kind of disappointed though
about some of the parts of it that came
out of it in the Senate um I think it
was better previously but um
unfortunately had to be kind of watered
down a bit to get it past um so it's
frustrating hearing people saying that
no it actually wasn't watered down
enough when it's art already already is
basically not almost not going almost
not not doing anything um so uh yeah I I
I personally would rather parking
minimums just be abolished entirely but
this bill doesn't do that it just um
provides a an additional way to get
around them um so I I think given the
um amount of compromise that's already
been given um that this really ought to
be a simple bill that we can come
together around to um increase the
state further
comments representative frct thank you
Mr chair
um I think I support 2third of this
bill um the
parking I think eventually we're going
to find that parking requirements are
Market driven if a developer doesn't
have enough parking spaces for his
prospective tenants then he's not going
to be able to rent the space and on the
other side of it if a tenant doesn't
have enough parking spaces for the
amount of cars in the household then the
um tenant is not going to want to rent
in that particular building I think the
tax credit idea is good I'm in favor of
that I am hesitant on the idea of
transferring the um the adoption of
zoning rags
to the select board rather than to town
meeting um my
reservations are that it could lead to
what I call kneejerk or reactive zoning
um zoning I think is very important for
the way a town functions for the way it
looks and I think it should
be well thought out and I think it
should be voted on by the majority of
the voters not by a select Board of
three or five people thank you Mr
chair forther comments I will be
supporting the bill
though very good forther
comments seeing N I have a few today on
this
bill um since representative Frack
brought it up I would mention that I am
in total agreement with his his uh
comments regarding the local governing
body uh where the change the alternate
procedure for adoption of zoning
ordinances I think that's a horrible
idea I think the the local government
body
um making being authorized to adopt
amendments without going through the
usual warrant article is an extremely uh
bad
idea the new section on page one of
community revitalization tax relief
that's another idea that I think is um
not good um I think what can happen in
these situations and that again this is
a new section there I know I realize
some of these type of tax reliefs
already exist but anytime you do a tax
relief uh for one individual it's the
burden falls on somebody else and in
this case it's going to be the remaining
taxpayers um I I am always opposed
to special interest um
getting spe special
treatment and the rest of the tax payers
section is the parking um this section
is fraught with uh real real problems uh
written poorly and I'm going to go
through and explain why this is wrong
alternative parking solution when you go
through and read it it says that the
parking solution shall include and then
there's items number one item number two
item number three and number
four the problem
is that if you look at on line 14 about
3/4 of the way across is the word
or and what that means is and uh
representative Gallagher was saying he
wish that no parking was required that
word there intent or
not means that an alternative parking
solution could an items two three or
four require absolutely no parking
requirements now whether that's
intentional or not
um I'm not sure but that is a
horrible horrible um
Clause the next thing uh was what
represent majori brought up earlier in
the day during the
testimony when you go down to line 19
and we talk
about or not line 19 the item Roman
numeral 2 that starts on 23 the parking
solution the planning board shall be
required to consider all right well that
doesn't sound bad you got to consider
it then it goes on the next Roman
numeral it says the applicant can
demonstrate and 26 it says a planning
board shall be required to approve an
alternative parking solution proposed by
the
applicant so in one sentence it's saying
well you should consider in the very
next sentence or paragraph it says the
planning board shall be
required and if the planning board does
not
approve as required by line 26 it says
the planning board can request 30 thir
party review that's exactly 180 de out
from any other uh uh type of planning
board it's usually if the planning board
turns it down then it's up to the
applicant to request thirdparty review
this is this is 180 degrees of where it
should
be as uh others have uh mentioned that
most everything here can already be done
which is very typical with a lot of
these bills
zoning these can already be done by the
the the towns if they want to uh the
other last item I will talk about is um
transparency and one of the issues when
you start giving the planning board or
whatever legislative body the ability to
Grant tax tax
relief or even in one of the sections
there where it talks about zoning being
able being given to the uh local body to
to do rather than through warrant
articles and that is you open it up to
what I would call favoritism Andor
special interest or even uh a little bit
of swamp so for all those reasons I I'm
in favor of the
itl and and that's it further comments
or
questions seeing none bless the get on
I'm sorry oh yes go ahead I just wanted
to comment that uh so glad that this
bill came to this committee and and I
want to commend the uh chair for
speaking in the house saying that these
so-called housing bills are vetted to
this
committee thank you representative
Kellen thank you uh for your uh these
recent comments I will be vot voting in
support of this Bill thank you
representative PRI I would also like to
um second what uh representative gri
said I I have I feel very strongly that
all the bills housing bills especially
when they're sponsored by the housing
committee themselves should go to this
bill go to this committee for vetting
and I think it's very important thank
you for your comments you're welcome
representative
stavis thank you Mr chair and if I may
add that if those housing bills are
written by the housing committee heard
by the housing committee and voted on by
the housing committee and put on the
consent calendar then this body has no
opportunity to debate them on the
floor for the comments uh representative
K thank you Mr chair yeah I wanted to
Echo my my sentiment on this I I firmly
agreed with your comments on the house
floor and support that the housing bill
committee representative Gallagher um I
disagree strongly um I think that or I
originally chose to um s chose to
request to be on this committee when I
first joined because I thought we would
be it would be the opportunity to be
passing good housing legislation but
unfortunately that's not what happens
here unfortunately this is where good
housing legislation tends to go to die
which is why the special committee on
housing needed to be created in the
first place if you don't want bills to
be going to the special committee on
housing instead you could try actually
passing some through here instead of
just acting as obstructionists the whole
time so that workarounds for us are
representative power Mr chairman I'm I'm
really confused as to how the discussion
on the the content or merits of a bill
devolved into
bashing um committee assignments for
bills and to be clear the speaker and
the house clerk assigns the bills and
I'm I'm disappointed that there's been
comments with regards to where bills are
being signed and uh what happens in
these committees I I I feel that that's
very
inappropriate R wall thank you Mr
chairman as someone who sits as the
clerk on the special committee on
housing um I just thought it be makes
sense
to remind everyone that we don't ascribe
motives in the house whether that be as
to where the bills go that's up to the
discretion of the speaker and solely the
speaker and that's all I'm going to say
thank you thank you further
comments seeing none ask the clerk to
call a
yes Vice chairman in power could you
repeat the motion it's itl
yes okay ref Guffy yes again okay click
votes yes representative lales yes
representative Ella no
representative
Wallace
yes representative Brown yes
representative awood
yes representative kahill yes
Representative stavis no representative
T
no representative Gallagher
no representative Hicks no
representative how no representative
Priest No representative Frack
to8
okay I assume this will go
to the the regular
calendar and uh representative turot
will write the committee
report for the majority and who will be
priest okay and with that that closes
the exec session on 538 representative
priests do not forget this one
especially above everything I need
okay we have one more to go
um we'll wait for the clerk to get ready
okay last one of the day sen Bill 448
relative to Woodsville fire district and
we'll open up the exact session
representative kahill I believe you have
a motion yes I move uh itl on uh Senate
Bill
448 do we have a second on that Mr
chairman I'd like to Second
representative stavis will be uh
seconding that oh did you have your
hand
oh well if you'd like the second
representative Hicks well I was in on
your de side I think so yeah
representative Hicks will be the second
on that motion that thank you Mr chair
you're
welcome okay representative kahill would
you like to speak on this yeah sure I'll
take a stab
um I think that we shouldn't be getting
involved in this issue and that they
need to settle this issue on a local
level
thank
you uh further
comments representative
priest I think it's very important that
we wait until the uh Supreme Court uh
rules on this present Bill and then see
what happens and then go from there but
also I would agree with uh
representative kahill we shouldn't be
getting involved this is something that
that um uh the towns and The Villages
should have been working on and have
been working on in the past and then we
should not hinder their progress in
trying to consolidate these Services
thank you further
comments seeing none I have oh I'm sorry
representative F thank you Mr chair um
when you have disputes between parties
generally they go to the courts for
their
resolution that seems to be where this
dispute is right at the moment and I
think it should stay there and
legislation is not required at this time
if
ever further
comments I'll make one the prime sponsor
on this bill and her testimony made the
following comment this shouldn't be the
legislator's job to solve this I
couldn't agree
more when the clerk is ready could you
call a
rooll vice chairman power yes
representative
Guthrie
okay collect collect votes yes represent
salus yes representative
Keller yes representative Wallace yes
representative aood yes representative
Brown yes representative
kahill yes representive Davis yes
representative Tetro
yes representative majori yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative priest yes
representative Frack yes and Mr chairman
yes uh motion passes 17 to Zer okay this
will go on the consent calender without
objection uh representative Cahill will
be writing the report
unless you would like to let
representative hick right it no okay all
right so that closes the exact session
on uh senal 448 now before everybody
goes as far as I know that's it for us
in terms of hearings and executing for
this year unless we happen to get any
more uh bills come our way from the
Senate so what's
that well we'll see I guess it's not
over till it's over but as of right now
it looks like it's over pres of
Gallagher um I believe that we had
referred some voted to refer some um
bills to interim study earlier in this
um earlier this year um are we going to
uh schedule actual interm study sessions
for those or not I will get back to you
on that how's that how's that for
answer I have to go back and actually
look at at the bills but
as far as hearings on bills from the
house or the Senate we are complete as
of today all
right thank you representative Wallace
for sitting in and helping us with the
it